the interview between Tucker Carlson and
Vladimir Putin is out wow to say the
least the first 30 minutes are a history
lesson very interesting and I think
Vladimir Putin missed a tremendous
opportunity a tremendous opportunity for
him but fine so be it because Tucker
Carlson does in fact ask about the
jailed Wall Street Journal reporter and
he actually tried to get the reporter
home on the spot and Putin said nah we
we'll get into all of that and I'll talk
about why there was a missed opportunity
for Putin but there are some interesting
Revelations that came out of that
interview although Putin does say
several times these are not new
statements I've said these before I do
think in context with Tucker there are
some interesting things being brought up
as to the perception of of Russia of
Vladimir Putin and the war as it's
happening in Eastern Europe with the
United States Etc of course it's what
most people said that Vladimir Putin
views a CIA coup to uh took over Ukraine
got rid of yanukovich and there's a lot
more we'll get into I don't want to
break down the whole thing because again
a lot to talk about but we do have big
domestic news and that is Joe Biden you
know he had a bunch of classified
documents and uh for that he was facing
criminal prosecution but the doj special
special counsel has said he has mental
limitations and it would be hard to
convince a jury is anything but a doing
old man with memory problems who doesn't
have the uh force of will to actually
commit crimes I kid you not the doj is
actually saying look this guy's so
old he's going to look really
sympathetic for being a daughtering old
fool amazing that he's our president so
we'll talk about that and uh seriously a
lot to break down in the Biden
Department because he once again
referenced a dead politician or a former
politician now for the second time the
degradation of Joe Biden it's getting
absolutely crazy so there's a lot to
break down in terms of uh uh this Joe
Biden doj uh uh decision as well as a
Tucker Carls and Vladimir Putin
interview before we get started my
friends head over to cast brew.com it is
the best coffee you will ever have we
got Alex Stein's Prime Time grind two
times caffeine drink responsibly that's
caffeine could be dangerous and we've
got everyone's favorite appalachin kns
available in ground as well as rise with
the Berto Jr don't forget we got coffee
pods we got appalachin kns rise with the
Berto J stand your grounds Mr bcus
pumpkin spice experience and when you
become a member I'm sorry when you
support casper.com or become a member of
the Casper coffee Club you are
supporting not only the work we do here
because we sponsor ourselves our company
but you're helping to support the new
coffee house location which we're
building and in one month we'll be
holding a private live showing members
only 50 seats available tickets will
only be made available to Tim cast.com
members so head over to
timcast.net we will send out an email
with the link to purchase tickets for
our Martinsburg West Virginia live show
which is on the second floor of the
building where you will uh where the cbw
coffee shop will eventually be and the
goal for this uh show actually it might
be on the third floor I could be wrong
the goal for this show is to create a
space where there is a private club for
people like you to hang out and uh build
community watch movies share ideas and I
think it's going to be a lot of fun it's
a it's it's us countering these very
expensive Social Clubs that exist that
exist in these huge Urban strongholds
for Democrats they cost like $50,000 a
year Well ours is going to be a bit less
than that but might be like a thousand
bucks a year or something so not the
cheapest but in order to fund the staff
and have food and drinks on hand and pay
for the space it might end up being
about a hundred bucks a month or
something like that but become a member
at timcast.net
to also smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and share the show with
your friends join joining us tonight is
Bill otman hey hey thanks for having me
who are you what do you do hey I'm Bill
I'm the founder of Minds minds.com we're
open source decentralized social network
uh Ian is a co-founder as well talk
about once in a while we just launched
on
cnr.com
a new independent network based on the
Mind software hybridized with inverted
Tech so now if you go to the comments on
scanner.com that is you have to make an
account on this scanner Network and it's
all Federated on the fediverse and this
is what we're doing it's basically like
a social it's like it's own becoming its
own Twitter essentially right and it's a
News website with a staff that produces
content and everything yes wonderful we
also got aot hanging out hey everybody
what's going on my name is alad Al yahu
I'm a journalist here at timcast news
thanks for having me going did anyone
ever tell you that you look like the
lead singer from Young the Giant I
haven't got that um I usually get um I
forgot that act never mind I forgot his
name when he comes back to me I'll bring
it up there they're a good band by the
way they got some awesome songs songs
but we were watching a music video and
uh I was like oh look it's a lot's band
and then someone looked and saw like
what like they actually thought it was
you for a second I was like no your hair
looks really good today how it kind of
goes up on the side it's a good hair
thank you it was Ren who plays Ren in um
the league that's who I get who I get
Nick croll I get told I look like
nickoll I think a sexy version of him
but you can't see him but Mr bcus is
hanging out right here as well he
decided to come up to the studio and
he's sitting in front of me but we got
Shane Cashman know what up what up I
write about ghost her inverted world
this is why I'm reaching out to Joe
Biden uh the medium in the white house
he's so close to death you can see the
other side that's exactly right The Veil
The Veil is very thin in the white house
uh I'm also hosting the mines Fest April
27th with uh uh Ian's going to be there
we got Bill's going to be there we got
uh tripol is going to be there Jimmy
door a lot of great people you can get
the uh tickets right now at the Vulcan
gas company honestly it's like Destiny's
going to be there Lauren Chen's doing
stand up com
yeah it's going to be F Austin's always
a great time and I want to just give a
special shout out to Richie who got me
this banging shirt yo Richie knows my
style better than almost anybody I love
it so Richie your spirit is with me it
looks like one of his shirt it smells
good too Richie I wonder if he wore it
and didn't wash it just so I can smell
him but I like it rich story to the
shirt is that from somewhere no no maybe
maybe Richie Richie if if there is
Richie knows it's from New Zealand
Richie Jack the Fe on that's Fe a all
over the Internet check them out richs
greatest skaters on Earth yeah awesome
dude funny guy we got Serge PR bun yo I
am here I'm wearing merch from uh this
famous soda you might have heard of it's
not how you spell my name my name is
from s r g but uh yeah let's get to the
show just like a year and a half ago we
bought several cases of surge cuz you
can still buy it just order more it's
funny I mean I just don't like ordering
the super sugary stuff like we have
liquid death it's got 30 calories and a
tall boy so yeah all right let's let's
let's read the news go from cnr.com doj
will not seek criminal charges against
Biden due to his mental
limitations it could be it would be
difficult to convince a jury that they
should convict him of a serious felony
that requires a mental state of
willfulness holy crap they are saying
that Biden
is so old and broken he does not have
his own force of anymore or at the very
least to be fair you could not convince
a reasonable person that Biden has a
mental state of
willfulness I'm thinking about rean I
think they did this with Reagan do you
remember Ronald Reagan being like I've
got Alzheimer's and they're like okay
then you can't punish him for all the
war crimes he did or whatever he did in
the 80s he's like yeah I don't even
remember and they're like all right you
think Reagan was acting I think that
maybe they played the Alzheimer's thing
up to get out of like some of the some
of the stuff he done I that I I've heard
that that was his friends used it like
get stuff in the the into like law
actually if if if Biden cannot be held
accountable because of his diminished
mental state he cannot be president no
you're right so I did see a tweet from
Jack bobc and he was like because of the
uh uh the class because of the
classified documents we may not get a
prosecution but we may get the 25th
Amendment yeah right and that and that's
where we could remove Joe Biden for
being and then I don't know kamla Harris
I guess and they were talking about the
25th Amendment at the end of trump and
people were like they're using it for
Trump but they were setting this up no
no like when they announced the uh 25th
amendment panel was being created which
the 25th Amendment says like you can
basically remove an incapacitated
president so they're going to create
this committee and then vote out in
Congress that would have the ability to
make the determination if the president
was mentally unfit everyone's like
they're going to do this to get rid of
trump and then within like 10 minutes
everyone's like actually they're doing
this to get rid of B Democrats are
setting this up to get rid of Biden yeah
what was the lawsuit they were trying to
push forward that they said they can't
no this is criminal charges he will not
be criminally prosecuted for the crimes
he committed let me read in the report
it says in his interview with our office
Mr Biden's memory was worse he did not
remember when he was vice president
forgetting on the first day of the
interview when his term ended if it was
2013 when did I stop being vice
president and forgetting on the second
day of the interview when his term began
in 2009 am I still vice president he did
not remember even within several years
when his son Bo died and his memory
appeared ha
when describing the Afghanistan debate
that was once so important to him among
other things he mistakenly said he had a
real difference of opinion with General
Carl ikenberry when in fact ikenberry
was an ally who Mr Biden cited
approvingly in his Thanksgiving memo to
President
Obama this is the doj being like uh this
guy has no force of will like there's
he's he's gone I thought you were going
to say ikenberry was a cartoon character
that Biden used to watch in the 50s
ikenberry was the Char character on the
on the lots of Berry cereal box so you
think he's going to make it to the end
of the term no really you don't think so
I don't what do you think is going to
happen I don't know I don't there could
be many things I did say this back in
like November I did a segment where I
was looking at all the news and I was
like Biden will be out he will be out
some way I I have to say like right now
it's hard to believe because it's
February and we're so close to the
election I think a reasonable conclusion
is man if if if if it came down to it I
had to put 10 bucks on he's in or he's
out he's out I think they're going to
have him do some type of sympathetic
step down where he's going to be like
this this corpse figure giving a speech
being I can't do this anymore it's for
the better of the country and they're
going to do that to make him yeah like
sympathetic to people well he won't make
it through that speech but he won you're
right they'll need AI be every speech he
has a gap yes like there isn't a normal
one he's speaking right now apparently
as well oh we should should we pull it
up I heard he was going live at like 4
yeah he did like some unscheduled speech
maybe he's talking about Putin I don't
know I just seen the chat people send he
speaking live right now so I mean I I
don't know if I care all that I don't I
just love that the people who who
thought kth was like Trump being
mentally deranged are okay with this one
by providing ammunition and material for
them to defend themselves W he is alive
coincidentally yeah I think he's talking
about Ukraine that's the time frame when
this broke out I have no proof what I'm
about to say but it's not unreasonable
to suspect that the Hamas OD what was
about to take place and break it up
before it
happened good timing on our part he just
walks off did did a hand just emerge to
tell him to come this way did you guys
see the uh I think so what the
coincidentally did you guys see the
interview he was doing time frame with
where the reporter goes off script and
immediately his hander like Mr bid Mr
Biden and he's like no I'm going to do
this anyway was about to take place and
wanted to break it up before it
happened I think he's remote controlled
dude there's a hand it's a camera I wish
it was a movie or something to laugh at
or is it a remote control I guess there
is a hand on the camera what if that is
the hand of the real when's the last
time he took questions like full-blown
press conference never yeah they've
always y he's skipping the Super Bowl
interview which is like a big deal yeah
I guess the second time he's refused to
do an interview like the president does
a Super Bowl interview it's like the a
big moment in the country really Trump's
like I'll do it and they're you know
they're not going to do it Trump though
you know I'm I I think it's important
for history's sake that everyone
remember this moment where you were a
moment you'll never forget when the doj
said Joe Biden's mental state had
diminished to the point of no longer
being a willful human being that is to
say this is the day when it was
determined by our executive branch the
president was no longer a sentient human
being this the thing if someone commits
like a crime but they're not mentally
aware you put them in a mental
institution you don't put them in the
jail necessarily take them to a hospital
because they weren't mentally prepared
or me mentally cognizant I I have a
story for you guys it's a story that
I've told maybe twice on this show when
I was about 14 in my neighborhood on the
south side of Chicago there was a rumor
don't know the exact details or how it
went down but this is the story that we
were told when we were children that uh
girl our age had been crossing the
street when an elderly man blew the stop
sign running her over she was crossing
in a crosswalk with a stop sign as an
Oldsmobile was coming up and she didn't
think it mattered because the car would
stop but it didn't and it ran her over
it was a very old man who was driving
and when he hit her he stopped instantly
she was now underneath his car not
knowing what he hit he put it in reverse
backing up crushing her head like a
melon splattering it that's what we were
told killing her and that if he had not
moved she would have lived the penalty
for this was they revoked his license I
mean what are you going to do there was
an older
man I mean apparently he was in his 70s
or something and is is did he commit a
crime or is he just incapacitated at
this point he should no longer Drive due
to his diminished mental state so they
determined based on this we will remove
his license now I don't know the full
details I'm sure the story was not 100%
that way that's just what we were all
hearing and everyone was saying because
like a girl our age like went to school
at the same time I don't know who she
was died but it was like friends of
friends do we want to wait for that
moment with Joe Biden no not for the
commander of the military when he
presses the button and then when a city
like Moscow is wiped out and we're
facing down the barrel of all of
Russia's icbms everyone just says maybe
we should impeach him now the thing is
the American people have not been privy
to a a real military loss in my lifetime
they don't understand what it means if
your commander slips up whether
intentionally or unintentionally and
causes the death of women your your wife
your wife and your children and your
families and your city is burned to the
ground because of some mistake that the
immediately he's removed from Power
immediately whether it's the president
the lead the general in charge they're
stripped of command if they do that well
people yeah not to make you guys uh
think worse of the guy but apparently he
walked off when we were watching him and
then he walked back out and then he said
that BB was the president of Mexico so
wait what
no don't believe
you you may not believe me but that's
what I'm getting from chat that's what
he said so and you guys don't believe me
about Joe
B wow here we I I don't believe he
walked back out that's that's what I've
been told I mean the stream shut down is
there some other video on something no I
don't know that's it was that the second
time he walked off that's I don't know
if there's if there's a first one they
said that heed walked off and came back
at some point he walks off after
reporter questions him then he comes
back reporters grilled him about his
age's memory apparently that's what
happen he took questions so well I
suppose we'll have to try and find that
on X or something yeah I don't know
maybe it's it's elsewhere but that's
what I was told so he won't be charged
in classified documents case because he
has poor memory oh my god well I don't
think you should be charged in that
stupid case anyway but not because of
poor memory just because why would you
charge a an ex vice president for
accidentally or for even intentionally
maybe so we have this let's let's play
clip from Newsmax so I don't know if he
came back out here we go something the
special counsel said in his report is
that one of the reasons you were not
charged is because in his description
you are a well-meaning elderly man with
a poor
memory I'm an elderly man and I know
what the hell I'm doing I've been
president I put this country back on his
feet I don't need his recommendation
that's totally his lawyer is going stop
shut up stop is your memory and can you
continue as president my memory is so
bad I let you speak what that's that's M
has no that's right though that's Dey
don't give it he's going to get you if
you remembered this you wouldn't let him
speak m is not my memory is fine my
memory take a look at what I've done
since I become president none of you
thought I could pass any of the things I
got passed how'd that happen you know I
guess I just forgot what was going on oh
they're they're at least he took a
question no no listen listen do a sarc
right now his lawyers are face palming
like the doj just let you walk you went
on television said no I'm fine he
literally says the doj says they're not
going to prosecute you because your
memory is no good no my memory's fine
you you literally just said prosecute me
yep right I think they're weaning him
off all the uppers so he can melt into a
pile of skin before they like sweep him
off the stage and then let KLA come in I
when they're like your memories I hear
your memories bad he's like like yeah my
memory is so bad he's doing the sarcasm
thing which is just indicating that he
does believe he has a bad memory I need
to fact check Serge he didn't say that
um Benjamin Netanyahu was the president
of Mexico he said Egyptian president
Abdul fata Eli allegedly was President
of Mex I apologize sorry and and okay
hold you hold on doesn't matter because
we have this from the post millennial
just in Biden says he will be president
for everybody whether you live in a red
state or a green state
it's incredible that's my Christmas joke
Ian Ian said this as we were pulling the
story up he's like he must be talking
about Christmas he's still in December
and then uh I I said he he was
addressing the North Pole most people
don't know this but the uh North Pole
the jurisdiction by which Santa Claus
rules is actually divided into seven
different states with uh Waring
political factions between uh
Republicans and the green party
Democrats don't exist up there for some
reason and so whether you're in a red
state or Green State uh this is not a
joke he said this dude yo let's roll
here we go said when I said when I we
pushed all these programs I said I'm
going to be a president of everybody
whether you live in a red state or Green
State God yo I whenever I see stuff like
this it just reminds me of um what was
it Doctor Strange Love writing the
atomic bomb
down like here we go baby everybody
should watch that movie tonight yeah but
the upside is Tucker's interview of
Putin actually gives me like Putin's not
demented at the very least maybe he's
got ulterior motives that we don't know
about but he's clear he's very he's
intelligent but he's a good he's a good
guy in every story he tells can we Putin
yeah oh yeah can we can we get like
Sheamus to make that joke where it's
like Joe Biden standing at the stage why
your memor is good and you know if you
live in a green State I told you and
then they and then he starts walking
away and then as soon as as soon as he
goes in the other room he goes all right
what's the next move we making we made
it off they're like Mr President the the
ACT worked they're not going to
prosecute you CU everyone believes
you're scile and decrepit he might be
doing that true true he might be doing
that I do believe I don't know if rean
did that or not I don't know but when
someone told me that he might have
played up the all he's an actor you know
rean was an actor the whole like well I
might go to prison for life or if I just
kind of play along with the whole
Alzheimer thing maybe I'll just get to
quietly live out my days right and
Biden's like yeah maybe I'll just play
this character of like yeah they they
have to 25th amendment him at this point
I mean if they're not going to prosecute
him because they're saying he's he's got
a diminished mental state if if they are
saying he lacks the will to be able to
to to be able to hold him accountable
for his crimes they've publicly stated
he could do anything he wants now maybe
that's what they want the cren scenes
love it they're tweeting about voting
for this guy no matter what his mental
capacity today they did one of them did
yeah yeah but this is why I say they're
evil because when it comes to the lies
on the corporate press about Elon and X
they immediately like they jump in line
and say oh the media is lying about Elon
and then when it comes to Trump they're
like they're telling the truth about him
that's right it's like we know who B is
your bread the Democrats and X you make
money on the platform and they and they
posted like we only made $400 you know
in the past pay period and I'm like yeah
so you're desperate to make more exactly
they they'll just say whatever it is
benefits them and if it's the
establishment narrative or if it's X
there like it their position makes no
sense I like personally I like them a
lot it's not I'm not refuting what you
guys are saying I don't know but I know
they're not really political guys at
least according to them they're like
dude we feel stuck in politics right now
don'ts I don't
care but who cares about these two guys
individually it's it's the issue of the
left grift yeah like their their
positions just to line wherever the
power is for them and they'll take it so
yes you have people like them you have
many others happy Bill Mah that Joe
Biden is mentally diminished and won't
be prosecuted and they would rather vote
for him than Donald Trump makes no sense
it's it's it's a trump derangement
syndrome is is is going easy on these
guys yep Trump psychosis syndrome or
something if Trump acted like this they
would have been having meltdowns in the
streets they would have had an all over
TV people be pointing out how slow he is
they'd be putting it up against what he
was like 6 years ago and they' be like
look how much worse he is it would be
don't vote for this guy that guy is bad
this I wish they would give Biden the
treatment man I wish they would show
people I feel bad what if Joe Biden was
speaking in context and the
post-millennial with this
clip they just you know pulled a fast on
us and Biden was talking about
Republican states or states that have
legalized marijuana right and for those
that aren't watching this Tim just that
from a Cen scene tweet that's what that
was so he was clearly referencing states
with recreational man refering the green
party it was the green party it was
interesting that Tucker was pushing
Putin on like well why don't you just
call up Joe yeah that was funny and and
Putin like didn't seem to think that
that would be productive for
understandable reasons but but it I I
actually appreciate that kind of a
question because I feel like world
leaders actually don't call each other
up a lot they have their kind of hand
lers talk and it's just Putin was way
wrong on this one he should ABS Putin
I'm sorry call I watched that that
interview and I won't get into all of it
but he missed a lot he has proven
himself to be an ineffective leader and
just for the for for the con I want to
save it for the next segment we do
because it's a big story but I just want
to say in this context he absolutely
should call Joe Biden because then he's
going to be like Hey Joe this it's your
brother Joe oh what do you need $100
billion
oh tell me where to wear it wire it to
Putin okay he can get anything he wants
he can call him and be like uh you know
we should uh get our troops out of
Ukraine oh whatever you whatever you say
brother what what are you doing calling
me from Russia with a Russian accent
he's going to be like it's how I talk
now oh okay just just take the
opportunity joke it's joke it's funny
joke I think when Putin they're like
when Tucker was like why don't you just
call Joe and and work some stuff out so
we can avoid World War II Putin was like
ah it's already taken care of we don't
need to worry about it like he he seemed
like they have people and the Americans
have people that are already decided
we're not going to have World War I
that's what it seemed like it sounded
like I like that it seems easier for
Tucker to interview Putin than it is for
him to interview Biden right like yeah
Biden's not going to sit down with
Tucker they trotted out all the people
even Hillary last night talked to
condemn this interview he could go to
Russia and interview Putin Western
journalists haven't even bothered
interviewing Joe
Biden y I think he interviewed on the
Weather Channel once did he no but it
was funny because when Tucker said that
he he was wrong but he was right okay
like here's the issue Russia came out
and said Tucker Carlson is incorrect A
lot of people have reached out to us for
interviews with Putin but we just turned
them down but I got to push back on
Russia the people contacting Vladimir
Putin for interviews are not journalists
they're State actors and propagandists
and smear Merchants Tucker Carlson may
be one of the only journalists whove act
who's actually tried to get an interview
with Vladimir Putin so the issue is when
Tucker's talking about Western
journalists he he's referencing like you
know Libby Emmons or um Steven Crowder's
team or James O'Keefe like why isn't
James o'keef tried to interview because
he's not talking about the New York
Times CIA assets or The Daily Beast or
rolling CIA Stone right I'm kidding by
the way but like as if anyone thinks
these these news outlets are anything
but mouthpieces for the state come on
you're full of it you can watch James
O'Keefe and I what what what I love
about how they go after James is that
when he was doing these sting operations
like Google they were like he's far
right and he was like are you implying
that by going after Google they're far
left like I don't understand what your
point is he goes after these big tech
companies and then immediately the media
calls him far right for doing so or they
claim that he only goes after left
lefting organizations and he's like is
is Google leftwing or they just a big
tech company but they expose themselves
when they do this you take a look at um
we me we can mention this briefly like I
don't know if you guys saw this NBC News
it advocated for putting hichi of Libs
of Tik Tok in
prison you see this they did a big
thread where they were like following
several posts by Libs of Tik Tok bomb
threats happened and then on NBC News
this lady's like is there a possibility
we can hold her accountable for this and
the guy's like well she didn't do the
bomb threads but you know that's where
they're going with it well they would
love for stochastic terrorism to become
like actual law oh because then it's
just anything's interpretable as being
illegal speak like at that point saying
like I just play don't like Joe Biden
that's a crime you know oh won't someone
rid me of this priest becomes a capital
offense do you think that leftism in
general is inherent to corporate like
totalitarian corporate technocracy like
is it just is that a leftist thing the
idea of like governing with corporatism
no no no corporatism could be left or
right uh there's this kind of like the
interesting thing about the fascists and
uh uh I should not the Nazis is a better
a better way to put it is that it was a
pseudo market system but there was an
ideological capture as opposed to
Communism where you had State capture so
with the Communists in Russia they're
basically like you will do as you are
told you report to us with the Nazis
they were like how come you aren't
producing steel for our effort you're
not a traitor are you and then they no
no no no I'll do it and it was more like
with the nais it was cancel culture it
was fear that you'd be shunned
ostracized or worse as time progressed
and so everyone just fell in line
because I mean Crystal knock for
instance like just Mass Rampage of
destruction of and targeting of people
there it was fear that you'd be targeted
too if you fell out of line with the
Communists they wore uniforms marched to
your house and shot you in the face you
know what I mean so they were like right
there telling you what they were doing
and I I will state this too with the
caveat I read one academic paper on it
talking about the economic structure of
Nazism and how it was how it permeated
through Germany so it's probably much
more nuanced than that the Nazis had
like no no I mean they they masked like
a great Revival of their economy
basically by building tanks and they
were telling everyone they were building
cars and then they were like we have no
way to make profit on what we're doing
but we're amassing resources to build
build build build build because their
whole plan was just to conquer foreign
land and then repay their debts through
through riches you know conquered it it
was just a mess of a mess of an economy
and it looked so good on paper let's
let's talk about Vladimir Putin so we
have a bunch of stories to break down
the interview Tucker Carlson uh had with
Vladimir Putin is officially up on
Tucker carlson.com it is a must
mustat there there are some there are
some dry points I must admit the first
half an hour is a history lesson I
literally fell asleep forgive me but I'm
like I'm falling asleep listen it's like
1826 the r the state of Roose and the
the baptism and I'm just like this is
okay Tucker actually caveats the
interview in the beginning saying we
thought he was pattering for time but
there was no time limit to the interview
so he's like I genuinely believe Putin
was expressing his statement that there
is a historical claim to Ukraine we have
and I agree with Tucker and I I I don't
see why anyone in the US anyone in the
west even the government would take a
different view than Tucker did Putin is
explaining that historically Ukraine is
theirs that's basically what he's saying
and that shows motivation for for this
conflict but one of the biggest issues
that we we had uh mentioned leading up
to this interview was whether or not
Tucker Carlson would ask about Evan
gershkovich The Wall Street Journal
reporter who has been in jail for over a
for just about a year turns out Tucker
Carlson not only did ask Putin about
this journalist but actually requested
that Putin release him into his custody
as a sign of good faith to return home
Bravo Tucker Carlson wow and Putin made
the biggest mistake of the night he said
no he did say a deal could be could be
could be made
interestingly he went on to say that
this this 30 I I believe he's 32 he was
caught red-handed with classified
information and he was under the
direction of US Agencies he may be a
journalist but we know who's really
pulling the strings and he was seeking
secret government information
confidential classified information
which basically makes him a spy now I'll
just say this the big narrative leading
up to this interview was that was that
Tucker Carlson was a mouthpiece for
Vladimir Putin and that Vladimir Putin
was going to lie propagandized to
justify his invasion of Ukraine and not
to believe him the fear was that Tucker
Carlson was giving a platform to a war
criminal imagine how bad it would have
been for the Western media and the Press
when they were forced to report Tucker
Carlson returns home with Evan
gershkovich saving his life from Russian
jail Vladimir Putin agrees in a good
faith effort and Returns the American
journalist home Tucker Carlson would
have taken the headlines across the
board the interview would would become
the biggest bigger than it already is
and it would put everything Putin says
on a pedestal but Putin made that
mistake and he said you know what do I
get out of it we'll think about it Putin
should have just said absolutely Mr
Carlson I want you because then when
Tucker Carlson's plane landed every news
Outlet in the country would have a
reporter waiting at the airport there
would be 10,000 cameras Tucker Tucker
Tucker what happened Evan what's going
on and everything then said in the
interview would be 1,000 fold wow I
think Putin's a straight up extremely
cynical political actor however and if
he was able to get uh for Britney
grinder he traded Victor bout for that
um that was I'm reading it was only in
December uh 2022 so Putin knows he could
get a lot for this journalist and I
think he knows and we're going to be
seeing more of this around the world um
China's going to be doing more of this
or has been doing a lot of this too
we're going to be see a lot see a lot of
this happening in Iran too but
kidnapping and then these Rogue cynical
political regimes trying to exchange
those for political prisoners that are
serving in the US who are actual
criminals I don't believe this Wall
Street Journal um Evan gershkovich um
he's only I think 32 is any sort of spy
journalism is illegal in um Russia so um
I think I need to commend Tucker Carlson
for even asking about this though um I
need to give him credit especially with
all the hype surrounding this interview
and leading up to it um I don't know so
again right after commenting Tucker I do
have to say though when he did interview
Kanye he did cut out certain portions I
don't know if this is the full interview
that he did conduct I don't know if in
the next couple of weeks we're going to
see a leak of other footage go down but
I wasn't able to see all of it but from
what I saw um I think Tucker did a a
relatively Fair job did he uh he didn't
bring up Snowden at all did he no no I
don't think so I don't think so that's
kind of been under the radar Snowden
over in Russia also uh what's her name
that accused Joe Biden of sexual assault
Tera re T Reed she's in Russia I don't
want to be she fled to Russia yeah she's
there now she just did an interview with
uh God who was it was it Ivory Hecker
did an interview with somebody I'm I
can't believe Putin didn't just say yeah
yeah that would have been truly epic and
I don't think he had considered that
well he could get so much for it got
Victor no but but I understand what
you're saying
that's he got The Merchant of death for
a WNBA player that's crazy but just
think about I mean in this interview
which we and we'll get into this in
Greater detail he said that he
approached Bill Clinton about joining
NATO and that Clinton said yeah actually
yes but then later that night came back
and said you know what we talked about
it no it's not going to happen the there
were there were key narrative points
Putin clearly wants to be heard unless
you know what to be honest maybe he does
not care at all one way or another what
the American people think i' I'd imagine
that as the president of a country that
is currently at war with the West he
would want to propagandize the West as
much as possible to shatter sentiment
any favor towards funding and supporting
Ukraine which is actually just NATO War
efforts and that's how you do it what
value do you get from some Wall Street
Journal guys he's is one dude but you
could amplify the power of that
interview so you know I I think
ultimately for for the United States
it's a good thing Putin misstepped here
and didn't do these things when it comes
to the propaganda he did say in the war
of propaganda it is very hard to defeat
the United States they control the media
like he knows what he's up against and I
also think when it comes to the Wall
Street Journal journalist he probably
doesn't want to show like weakness you
probably see it as weakness to give into
an interview and say like I'll release
someone just because Tucker Carlson
asked oh I disagree you think so
strength you think it's strength for him
to be like okay since Tucker brought it
up it'll be good it'll look good for me
publicly to release someone instead of
doing on his own coition absolutely if
he's like the good faith of you coming
here is enough is all I you come to me
to allow me to speak to you and those
who follow you to share the views that
we have knowing that our countries do
not agree for your efforts I will
release to you Evan gershkovich and I'm
telling you like every journalist would
have 10 photographers waiting at the
airport as the plane is landing all the
cameras are going to be filming it from
every possible angle it would have been
the biggest story in the world right to
be fair it probably already is the
biggest story but it would been
substantially larger and it and it's I
imagine the worst thing for the West
that Tucker Carlson not only shared
Putin's narrative but that Putin showed
to be amicable imagine coming back and
say and Tucker saying they are lying to
you about the position of Vladimir Putin
and why he's at war in Ukraine they are
lying to you about who he is he has even
as a sign of good faith released to us
this reporter Putin's bad at what he
does I mean he's really good at a lot of
things he does but this was his massive
opportunity I I I'm surprised he didn't
say yes the backlash to the interview
though is like did no one watch the
Oliver Stone stuff it didn't happen that
long ago and like you get the same
feeling he's a he's a Charming
intelligent guy whether you like him or
not like he's good at interviews I think
he rehashed too that he is a Russian
irid dentist and I know it's cliche to
say at this point but he does believe
that the collapse of the Soviet Union
was the biggest like geopolitical
strategy and he was a part failure
failure and one of the well it depends
on who you ask um so I do think he's
still cynically thinking about these
things he's wants as much of Ukraine as
he's going to be able to take and if
there is a ceasefire in Ukraine I'm sure
down the line he'll be interested in
taking another bite of it and if there's
any part of NATO that collaps with
Estonia and lvia um I'm sure he'd want
to take a chunk of those too because
again he sees those as a part of Russia
um all of the former USSR so uh it's bad
and dangerous and I and I think we need
to be more cleare eyed about the threat
he poses but I can also give you one
very very obvious reasonable reason why
he did not release this person it's very
easy for us on the surface to say look
at the political PR opportunity the
other reality is that Evan gershkovich
actually has very serious classified
information in his brain oh that's true
that simply by speaking to the CIA would
compromise the security position of
Russia so he will never be released yeah
I see it is possible I think for a
journalist to be over there and be a spy
we know there spies they've been
infiltrated over here for years you know
it it's definitely possible I don't
think they have free speech and a free
media in Russia though but but it's the
it's the you know it's the subliminal
the Lial and the super Lial right the
sublim the super Lial being like an
American reporter working in Moscow just
quite literally reporting whatever is
going on making sure that information
comes to the American public that's the
that's the on in your face then you have
people who like maybe at one point
worked for an industry or whatever and
they're over there and they learn things
and they post on social media but the
subliminal is like under the surface one
way or another reporting to a US agency
to deliver information and so you know
when we have like uh shinua or RT or
Sputnik these are just regular
journalists mhm uh to be fair like
shinua they're reporting to the Chinese
Communist party so like there's no
really you know there are they spies but
their work is above board it's super
Lial it's like they're quite literally
saying whatever you tell me I'm going to
share with China and the Chinese
Communist party but we do have spies
probably sneaking across the southern
border right now for China and uh we
know it's happening so for this to
happen I I got to be honest when they
announce something like a reporter got
arrested my immediate thought is not oh
no they've they've arrested an innocent
journalist they must be evil my immedate
thought is like interesting I need to
hear more about this because innocent
till proven guilty I I don't I don't
trust Vladimir Putin but at the same
time I don't see him creating this kind
of problem and PR problem unless unless
it means something yeah the the arrest
of gers uh uh gershkovich means that
people in the United States are going to
be aggressive towards Russia and he
knows that so there there's there's
there's a reason and uh I'll say it
again you know on the surface I'm saying
it was an opportunity to release him I
wonder if gersic actually learned
something so serious that he cannot be
allowed to speak to uh to the
Americans or to the West in general that
would be crazy I mean probably I like
the part where Putin says uh Tucker asks
who blew up to nordstream and Putin goes
you did he goes Tucker goes I was busy
that
day and then Putin says the CI didn't
have an Alabama
CIA CIA yeah Cia didn't have an alibi
who else could sink to the bottom of the
Baltic Sea this is uh this is an
interesting one this is from the same
interview Putin slams us and Bill
Clinton for deceiving Russia over NATO
membership as he trashes Biden Praises
Trump and warns there no there's no
stopping his supersonic missile system
this is interesting Putin says that Bill
Clinton offered Russia a place in NATO
but was overruled by his staff so
basically what happens is
Putin was like look in the 90s I meet
with Bill Clinton and there's pictures
of it Tucker posts picture includes
pictures in the interview and I said
look if Russia wants to join NATO would
that be possible and Bill Clinton said I
think so yeah and then comes back later
that night for dinner or whatever I
think that's what he said and Clinton
says you know we talked about it it's
not going to happen Putin said the
reason was the US supplies pressure on
all the NATO member states and they vote
the way the US wants having some a
nation powerful as Russia as large would
mean that US influence would be
compromised to a certain degree within
NATO I'll say outright that is Vladimir
Putin's propaganda on this look I'll
tell you first and foremost obviously
the US exerts the most influence over
NATO especially when we're footing all
the bills but also his reason for why he
got kicked out of the club I'm not going
to take it at 100% I think there's some
truth to it but he's giving you the I'm
always the good guy
narrative yeah I mean in terms of the
nordstream stuff did you see that this
was a while back but the New York Times
had a headline that was like it's better
that we don't get the truth it's better
that we don't know that that headline
was the creepiest one it's New York
Times um oh you're looking for the
recent stuff yeah but it's just bizarre
I mean Biden just point blank said that
we did it basically he told Tucker
Carlson you ukine War can be over in a
few weeks also there's no stopping Elon
Musk very interesting oh yeah the the
the the the Ukraine war stuff with Putin
is exactly what everyone already heard
and I gota be honest I was saying this I
don't think we're going to hear things
from Putin that we haven't already heard
there were a few things but even Putin
said several times these are not new
statements what happened with Ukraine
very obvious Putin said we never agreed
to allow NATO to expand against our
borders they started doing it anyway
we kept saying please stop please stop
they kept doing it they kept Building B
building bases and we said please stop
and they said don't worry it will and
they kept doing it anyway and then he
said the CIA staged a coup in in Ukraine
with
yanukovich which led them to the
position they're in now and it was uh it
was interesting he said what happened
was this is this is why they don't want
you to hear this interview this why they
didn't want Tucker to do it Ukraine was
in a free trade agreement with Russia
that allowed open border customs they
could ship goods in and out when NATO
and the EU began knocking on the door of
Ukraine Russia said this will flood our
Market if Ukraine gets similar access
into Europe all of that labor and
products and and services will enter
Ukraine and then with an open border on
our side for open Customs border we then
have to deal with a flood to our market
so we told them if you do this we close
our border yanukovich the time president
of Ukraine had to make a decision how
much money is to be gained or lost due
to these agreements and uh we've
actually talked about this quite a bit
because I was I was I was in Ukraine
when this was all going down when the
maidan protests erupted and the issue
was that yanukovich was trying to figure
out whose side to take Russia was making
him an offer European Union is making
making them an offer in these big cities
like Kiev and closer to the West they
were very EU favor like they wanted to
be in the EU because access to the EU
not only meant more money but it meant
eventually shenan Zone which is free
travel Ukrainian could then do what many
people in Poland were doing go to the UK
and get a job and all of a sudden you're
making more money bad for people in in
in the UK he didn't like what what was
going on with this but a lot of people
from Eastern Europe would move to
Western Europe where the economy was
better so yovich had to make the
decision and uh when he it didn't look
like he was going to make the right
decision Vladimir Putin's making the
accusation the CIA staged a coup to oust
him people stormed his house his Mansion
started going through his belongings
like they were Vice journalists walking
through his house totally crazy he fled
to he fled to Russia over this he says
that was it like they staged a coup and
now here we are and then one thing led
to another the US says they're going to
support the opposition against him and
he's like why that means we're going to
build missiles in opposition to you and
then he's like we've got you know the
best missiles and you can't stop us and
and here we are I will say though for
what purpose maybe Eli wants to CH on
this one is the US involved and at this
point it
is I would say 100% % confirmed Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt to any sane human being
the United States is at war with Russia
for what purpose should we be engaged in
this I mean I'm not saying you do have
an opinion on it I'm curious your
thoughts though I don't like to call it
uh I don't like to say that we're at war
with Russia because we don't have boots
on the ground um fighting Russians
except there have been reports that
there are some special forces but I
still think that those are relatively
ambiguous but on paper we're supposed to
not have troops on the ground in Ukraine
right now right now we you're just
arming the ukrainians to be able to
fight back against the Russians that
invaded them the argument to continue
supporting the ukrainians is that if
Ukraine Falls um Putin will continue
trying to push Westward as the Russians
have been doing for centuries and
they'll eventually brush up against a
NATO Ally of ours and if they do that uh
no brush up um and be ambitious enough
to try to invade one of our NATO allies
more Borderland with Russia allows for
more uh risk of that conflict escalating
but NATO did that NATO inducting Eastern
European States into NATO put NATO on
Russia's border I think it's like a yes
in some areas it's also like a chicken
before the egg problem because Russia
says that hey this is what's triggering
us and heightening tensions between us
but these countries want to join because
Russia is aggressive towards them um so
like a chicken before the ACT thing I do
think if Estonia if if the United States
loses the political will to continue
having to to continue having NATO be a
Thing If NATO ever dissolved there
there's no reason for Putin not to
continue to push W Westward definitely
lvia Estonia um and as far as he could
get back into World War II because he's
a Russian aerid dentist Because he
believes that all those countries are a
part of Russia like just as he believes
Ukraine is and he and you know within
his lifetime within Putin's lifetime
those things were true that this was a
part of the USSR yeah that's that's a
great Point actually because Putin
literally opens the interview by saying
historically and this is effect Kiev was
the capital of Russia and then after he
he he breaks down in the first half an
hour of the Tucker interview how the
states broke apart and this resulted in
the the states of like Roose or whatever
he said coalescing around Moscow this
thus the capital moved and it Tucker
even says right in the beginning Putin's
position seems to be there is a
historical claim to Ukraine as a part of
Russia yeah and if that's true for
Ukraine I agree why would not it be true
for the other I we liberated um those
countries um during I mean during the
World War II and then um by forcing the
dissolution of the Soviet Union we were
able to liberate the Eastern European
countries from communism and I think
that's something we should be proud of
I'm curious what everyone thinks about
this for me that hour maybe 40 minutes
of a long build through history that
Putin gives for me leads up to this like
densification thing he talks about and
uh is that something we buy does you
think he really believes in that do you
buy that in good faith when he says he's
densifying Ukraine do you like I don't I
don't know I know there's aov that we
got to worry about there's clearly
something going on and and we also know
he brings up the Canadian Parliament
applauding the Nazi uh with with zinski
I say yes but when I when I buy uh a
dilapidated old house and then and
someone says why are you buying well I
got to get rid of the roaches that are
inside of it is that the real reason
that I bought the house no right do I
really want to get rid of the roaches
yes but the real reason about the house
is to clean it up take it over make a
profit and the reason I'm getting the
roaches is to that benefit so of course
he wants to get rid of the Nazis and the
aov and those who have held those views
because they Soviets fought the Nazis
they're enemies yeah but it's just like
you know he wants it's dangerous too
because there's no limiting principle
cuz I'm I'm looking forward to hearing
about the Finnish Nazis and the Nazis in
Estonia and the the Nazis in lvia what
about the Nazis here that's my the crazy
side of my brain when I hear Putin say
that I'm like and then you asking a lot
about why are we at war with them I'm
like well Operation Paperclip because we
got Nazis in the government still who
want to fight uh Russia and take and
take it back you know but maybe that's
crazy cu the cut scene 5 years later and
it's like a bun a bunch of Russian ships
soaring to the the shores of California
and Florida and we're like oh no it
happened right why why didn't we believe
Joe Biden hologram Hitler standing on
the sh and this is all a huge issue and
I mean maybe we go back to Joe Biden but
I think the Americans really deserve
competent leadership up top uh one way
or another I know we disagree
geopolitically but we deserve somebody
who at least seems like they are
actively making the decision with some
sort of Direction in mind um we're not
only having conflict right now in Russia
Ukraine's taking the back seat but uh we
just drone stried uh hezbollah's branch
in Iraq we just killed some militia
leaders there we had three of our
service people killed in Jordan not too
long ago also um I believe two of our
special forces were killed somewhere in
the Red Sea on a mission to try to
prevent more arms going to Yemen from um
Iran so you said a word I don't really
understand what is conf competence how
how does that work is that something
that the government can do is that can
ins still in people yeah I mean like if
you put a a smart sounding individual in
front of me instead of Joe Biden who
just seems like like kind of blabbering
and ridiculous but I hate to say Ronda
santis like figure that's no endorsement
I don't particularly like him but Ronda
santis generally sounds like he knows
what he's talking about he sounds like
he has some Direction only and after
running for president not during not
during I I I I honestly I can't think of
um a worse example no no like the santz
is better than Biden obviously but in
terms of a good salesman in government
who actually can pitch something and
make it sound believable Obama was that
and right now I don't know I couldn't I
don't if I can name somebody is there is
there someone in politics who could
really convince you of something well VI
could if true he's honest about stuff
could convince me of one thing that he's
a cynical politician trying to sell me
something in my
opinion He he'll hear something that's
in my opinion I I as I interpret it um
whatever wind direction he sees the
political winds blowing he'll hop right
on board and what triggered me the most
about that was this January 6 flipflop
yes um but uh with you I think we need
to be more cautious about very cynical
political act I don't know if it was a
full flipflop though I mean I think it's
possible on January 6 to see that it was
kind of like not a cool scene but also
not think that it was an Insurrection
like it's possible to have both of those
he cried about it I I think I don't I
don't it I don't trust him I really
don't I think he says a lot of things I
really agree with uh so I want he
because he want to win you over and I'm
cynical but like yeah I don't think the
guy if he runs again if he doesn't do
like a rumble podcast deal he won't be
the same of vacon 28 that I think he is
I think he had a good opportunity to run
as like the Trump number two while Trump
was uh we need a competent leader that's
going to be honest with people and be
like we're creating a new world order
this liberal economic order the time is
done of American dominance military
dominance we're creating something new
so let's get on board the US
Constitution is legit and we're going to
force this thing on the world that's
that's part of our bargain of yes we'll
go we're not going to be strong but
we'll be extra strong you will be free
we're going to peacefully allow for this
transfer to a new Global ordinance but
we're going to make sure that free
speech is at the center I want I want to
I want to jump to the next story but I
do got to give a shout out to this one
segment kassandre McDonald posted uh ELO
Putin called out Tucker Carlson for
wanting to join the CIA let's play it
good opposition committed a coup in ke
what is that supposed to mean who do you
think you are I wanted to ask the then
us
leadership with the backing of
whom who the backing of CIA of course
the organization you wanted to join back
in the day as I
understand we should thank God they
didn't let you
in it's it's me because it was actually
sped up and then down was Tucker looking
at going to the CIA joining the CIA I
like it is a serious organization I
understand my former VI in the sense
that I served in the first main director
at the Soviet yeah he was KGB talking
about he's trying very good and and
shout out to Tucker Carlson for keeping
that in there and you know is there any
other coverage of that or is he kind of
like exposing that that he wanted to be
in the CIA I think everybody knows yeah
yeah but let's let's jump to this this
is big news today the Supreme Court
heard oral arguments over the issue of
Donald Trump being removed from the
ballot on the under under the 14th
Amendment section three did you guys
listen to the oral arguments uh not all
of it but like half yeah holy crap the
Democrat lawyer was getting spanked by
all of them and many are suggesting it
was so bad it might be a unanimous
Supreme Court ruling no you can't remove
Donald Trump what the are you thinking
it was wild hearing katangi Brown be
like I mean she's the just woke Justice
and she was like it doesn't say
president it it's not in there and and
he's like she's getting angry and he's
like but we think the president's office
and she's like the President appoints
officers it's not in there gorsi said
the president commissions all officers
it's in the Constitution how is he an
officer himself he didn't appoint
himself yo it was it was absolutely wild
and uh basically there uh uh it it it
broke down amazingly let let me actually
just read uh give you some context from
the AP and then we'll talk a bit about
it they said the Supreme Court seems
poised to reject attempts to kick off
Donald Trump a def definitive ruling for
Trump the leading Republican candidate
for president would largely end efforts
in Colorado Maine and elsewhere to
prevent his name from appearing on the
ballot the justices could act quickly
possibly by super Tuesday conservative
and liberal Justice a like question
during arguments to Thursday whether
Trump can be disqualified from being
president again because of because of
his efforts to undo the 2020 election
their main concern was whether Congress
must act before states can invoke a
constitutional provision that was
adopted after the Civil War to prevent
former office holders who engaged in
Insurrection from holding office again
there also were questions about whether
the president is covered by the
provision now here's what's interesting
there's a lot of things that were
brought up in this hearing the arguments
that I didn't know so uh under the
United States is a statement in the 14th
amendment that you know you can't hold
office under the United States or
something like that and Trump's lawyers
argued the presidency is not an office
under the United States or an officer
under the United States senators are
officers of the Senate and the reason
why that matters is because the
impeachment clause and the emoluments
Clause that if the Supreme Court were to
determine that the presidency was
covered by this it would also mean the
president is able to enrich himself
through the office of the presidency
being exempt from the ments Clause so he
so the lawyer was like you need to
understand what this statement means and
your ruling pertains to many other areas
of the Constitution so more
importantly the uh president is not
covered in the 14th Amendment and one
thing Trump's La said was don't you
think they would have explicitly put the
president in there if they thought it
was the most pressing office to bar for
an
insurrectionist I think uh my argument
as to why the the framers of the 14th
did not do that is really simple the
reason why you can't be a senator or
Congressman or or hold any other officer
or being an appointed officer is because
the other states the the north did not
have say in those appointments or
positions or elections so if you are
South Carolina civil war ends then South
Carolina says okay this guy was an
insurrectionist who fought against the
United States let's send him to DC the
north says no no no no wait wait wait
hold on hold on no no no we say no to
that but we can't vote on that so we're
laying it out in an amendment to the
Constitution to outright say don't do
that because we have no say now as for
the presidency well we get to vote on
that so we don't need to lock out
someone from being president because we
can choose through a Dem through the
Electoral College and through our system
whether or not the president will be an
insurrectionist in fact for for actually
says Congress can by two3 vote override
this restriction so it's actually really
simple if New York gets a v a vote in
who is being sent to the federal
government then they're fine with it if
they don't you are barred therefore it's
actually really simple the other issue
oh man this was wild gorsek was just
steamrolling the Democrat it was
spanking dude it was an absolute
spanking this guy was like when you when
the as soon as an office holder commits
Insurrection they are instantly
disqualified and so he's like okay what
would compel then a lesser officer of
the United States to follow the orders
of this person he had no answer none
none whatsoever imagine what that means
he was the Democrats are arguing that on
January 6 Donald Trump waged
Insurrection against the United States
and for the next 14 days should not have
been president and no one should have
followed his orders so what would happen
in a circumstance where their View
would be upheld someone goes uh it was
this was actually asked I think Alo may
have asked this so when Joe Biden
released the funds to Iran he waged
Insurrection against the United States
and now nobody should follow his orders
ever again that's what they're saying
the if the Democrats have their way it
is instant civil war Civil War no no no
but but I mean it the idea would be the
moment any actor in the government
believes within their own person that a
president engaged in an Insurrection
against the United States they are Duty
bound constitutionally to defy all
orders legal or otherwise because they
have disqualified themselves from office
that is the stupidest thing I have ever
heard that's the Democrat position on
why Trump should be removed and the
justices were like are you insane and
not literally saying that but gork was
just like if you don't have an answer
that's fine and the guy was muttering
and didn't have anything to say to it
I'm no legal expert so I won't speak to
the legales involved here but the
strategy of among some Democrats to try
to disqualify Trump uh through legal
means uh might actually be a threat to
democracy and if Trump supporters were
as threatening and violent as they often
imply that I think this would be a more
dangerous trigger moment for somebody
who is leading um is the presumptive
Republican nominee former president at
this point just something extremely
dangerous over something as ambiguous as
trying to call what happened on January
6th an Insurrection completely
outrageous uh dangerous and I mean I
hate to adopt their language but an
actual threat to democracy as people in
our country understand that was the one
thing I was worried about while I was
listening to I think it was about an
hour in I was like uh are we not going
to talk about what Insurrection means
are we not going to Define that word
they're calling out other words I'm like
cuz I'm like the death of language right
they're we're all just going to adopt
Insurrection now in this argument but
then at a certain point I think it was
after an hour they were like well uh
Insurrection is a organized violent
effort and then it might have been
Jackson who was like well this a chaotic
one could also do it maybe it was
someone else but and then he goes it's a
that's a riot right so they did break it
down a little bit I'm I'm done playing
this game you are mentally deficient if
you think January 6 was an Insurrection
Insurrection referred to Civil War
taking up arms standing on a borderline
and shooting at Union Officers okay
they're not talking about a bunch of
unarmed people knocking over barricades
and breaking Windows right that that's
just it's just I'm I'm I'm done with the
with the manipulation I remember
everyone you know in in the immediate
aftermath of
uh j6 happening saying well he Trump
used the word fight I'm like so is every
other president or candidate ever you
know I thought of Teddy Roosevelt the
man in the arena he talks about having
blood on your face doing politics you
know it's like people use these words
you're just using it as you know
evidence in your
narrative the fearmongering of trying to
dress this up is something that it
wasn't um is evident there was none of
the actual political Machinery of some
sort of coup or Insurrection happening
in the background we actually spoke to
the Secretary of Defense on this show I
think it was a little bit over a year
ago who said obviously none of that was
happening in the background all of these
people would have been necessary to do
any sort of coup obviously none of that
happened none of his cabinet was on
board Mike Pence didn't try to pull
anything um although Trump might have
tried to get him to Pence didn't right
there was no other electors found found
in Georgia or what have you so well now
that we're talking about actual Civil
War should we bring up our our seventh
guest oh yeah flag bring it over sure I
guess this thing's going to BL civil war
flag or is it over yeah we have an
actual civil war flag it is gigantic too
don't drop it on bcus look at this bcus
is sleeping on the bubble wrap Billman I
like that it did a coffin yeah laid to
rest a good metaphor
for it's in the shot as much as we can
as much as we can get it right now so
this is uh this is an actual Flag 13
star US Naval flag used in the Civil War
in battle um so this is from Terren and
Sabina um deot who are investers in
scanner and so this is a 13 us 13 star
US Naval flag for the brig rival likely
an English Blockade Runner captured
during the Civil War so it was on a ship
wow um and what's the value of it a lot
I I don't know we need to say a number
but it's a historical Relic yeah I mean
you can so can I wear it technically
we're going to have to mount it and
hopefully we can get in the new studio
it's shot to it might be too big
it's it might be but maybe maybe we can
maybe we can have it vertical it's
because uh I think it would touch it
would touch you want to do that 5T by
11t 11 5 by 11 5 by 11 that's not so bad
it can't it can't go vertical though but
11t wide cuz um got to make it happen
you could D it from the wall I think we
could no no no outside the I wouldn't
want I want it it would be great to be
in the studio so professionally mounted
do we got to we got to frame it no uh no
it just needs to be sewn onto a mounting
Fabric and then it can be hung I think
we should frame it sure I think we
should we should give it a glass case
keep it safe that would be better
probably non-reflective look let's see
if we can figure out how to get a custom
large glass frame it's going to be very
expensive to make a 5x1 glass frame but
absolutely must be done for something as
incredible as this thank you teren and
can have it in the new studio mounted on
the wall you said it's been shot up too
this flag took bullets I mean so check
out the uh I don't know if you can zoom
in on that Serge no no we do not have
that but it's riddled with bullet holes
you can see the bullet holes or or you
know I don't know necessarily that
they're bullet holes it has holes all
throughout it 170 year- Old Flag Focus
it's a beautiful flag shout out American
flag it smells good it smells like
probably the museum that it had been
kept in I'm not sure I felt like a
soldier driving down here dude it's like
it's like falling it's almost like
falling apart when you touch it but it's
worth touching get your fingers on it
before it gets framed if you have it yet
I would not recommend touching just
finger it very lightly oh oh one little
dip put your index finger on there and
understand what they yeah respect it
treat it properly the FL you know don't
finger the flag Don't finger the flag
ladies and gentlemen God that thing is
beautiful man amazing who was it that
that donated that it's it's on loan uh
to timcast uh from Terren Coman who is
investor of scanner also mind Terrence
nice job if they're if they're okay with
us getting a customade glass oh yeah
that's what they would love okay then
perfect we'll do it I imagine that would
be like a hefty Penny but yeah it'll be
at least yeah done no question and we
could maybe get a little card that says
like on loan from Terren and then like a
link to their thing or something you
know whatever that's really cool man
that's amazing wow that's things so what
was the Civil War about again why did we
fight the Civil War some dudes wanted
like iron or something well according to
Nikki Haley it was because States wanted
their freedom and the government was
just not okay with that what was the
Civil War about was it money cotton
controlling the economics of the South
uh it was slavery British British
Virginia trade depends on how you ask
the question why was the Civil War
fought is a very different question from
what caused the Civil War what caused a
Civil War slavery the expansion of
slavery and the contention between free
states and slave states which had
resulted Ed in Bleeding Kansas
widespread fighting that had been
happening predominantly in the Kansas
territory but also in other parts of the
country and uh ultimately led to an
election where Abraham Lincoln what
didn't receive a single vote in seven I
believe seven states or actually I don't
think he received a single vote in any
of the states that eventually went on to
seced so I think it was 11 but uh why
did they fight the South fought because
they were invaded yeah Shelby foot's my
favorite Civil War writer and uh he said
that the north thought they were
fighting the Civil War and the South
thought they were fighting the second
like American Revolution
the best book which book oh GE well just
I think it's called the Civil War it's a
whole series that I think he spent maybe
20 years writing uh some he wrote
fiction about the Civil War and also
non-fiction and she look up his
interviews he's no longer with us but
amazing writer I know they call it the
war of Northern aggression right A lot
of people in the South refer to it as
it's like in the Putin interview he said
that in Russia they refer to World War
II as a Great Patriotic War um I think
okay it feels a little bit different
like I don't want people in the South
being taught that it's a war of Northern
aggression because that's not well what
Shelby foot meant was that there were
people in the South who might have not
had slaves and they just saw like
Marauders in their homes burning things
down like uh with the total war from
Sherman yeah but they were fighting for
the right they figh to but they were
fighting to survive uh Sherman doing you
know total war but that's not saying
everyone in in the South but there were
definitely people like I spent a year in
Georgia where Sherman kind of went
through and sometimes it wasn't Sherman
it was people pretending to be with
Sherman to go maraud and take over
farmland and those people started
fighting to themselves like there's a
lot of people in the chat who were
saying it was a states rights versus
Federal issue I strongly recommend uh
you guys like read some academic papers
and read the letters from many of the
generals I I had a great time went to uh
uh Jackson's I think I went to two of
his houses and one one of them was crazy
they had a musket in the kitchen this is
what I love about Second Amendment they
have a musket in the kitchen for
shooting Critters so like anyone could
just grab it off the wall open the back
door and then wait for a rabbit or
something something or a beaver or who
knows and just bang a gopher and then
you throw it in the stew and you're just
like it came in my backyard it is man
and the gun was just there but uh yeah
we went to uh their houses I read I read
their letters learned about their wives
and uh certainly it is a very
complicated issue with many different
views but uh while the general view most
people would give you is it was fought
over slavery it absolutely was not
fought over slavery it was caused by the
issue of slavery which like Bleeding
Kansas existed before there was a
question of states rights people were
murdering each other in in the Kansas
territory John Brown was blasting people
in the face you Hans Christian heg
wasn't even an American and he came here
to tr as as an abolitionist slavery uh
uh was was dissolving in other parts of
the of the world as as an institution
and so it could not be an issue of
state's rights when Bleeding Kansas was
happening seven years up to the lead was
leading up to the Civil War some argue
Bleeding Kansas actually is the Civil
War and we just view the Civil War as
like because it was when this when the
government actually became actively
involved but Bleeding Kansas gnarly 7
years of of bloody conflict and
bloodshed abolitionists and pro slavery
forces were fighting in various
territories over whether or not they
would be slave states or free states the
slaveholding states believed that with
Abraham Lincoln's election he would not
only stop the expansion of slavery he
would get rid of it and I believe
Lincoln's position was no no no you can
you can keep it we just won't have it in
any new territories so they were just
like nah we're not going anywhere near
anybody who opposes this there were four
candidates running one guy I love this
he was just like I'm not going to talk
about slavery at all and so nobody cared
for him one guy was like more slavery
one guy was like uh completely get rid
of slavery Abraham Lincoln was
supposedly like the compromised
candidate where he was saying you can
keep it but no more as soon as he got
elected seven states said this is it
we're going to succeed before he even
got inaugurated the session started and
that's so what what ends up in the
fighting over the Civil War is the north
invaded the South yeah this is and I
don't want to be an apologist for war
and I don't want to but I just want to
give Nuance to both sides of that war
and I'm talking about Georgia in
particular with the Confederates there
were these were people who whose fathers
were invaded by Britain and their houses
were burnt down not necessarily
slaveholders uh and then they saw as a
second like American Revolution because
then they were invaded by they saw the
north as as an invasion but then you
know there's people on the on the North
in in German's army during the march of
the sea who you know weren't also Angels
they were killing freed slaves uh who
were following them just because they
didn't want to be followed anymore so
it's not to say every person who fought
in the Confederacy owned slaves or 5% of
the US population yeah but they were
fighting on behalf of a government who
is fighting for the ability for you to
still have them I would still say not in
the Constitution not all yeah to what
how they interpreted it so although
they're defending the right to you know
so not slave owners directly but still
defending that right and I'm sure they
were propagandized in different ways to
believe different things yeah no uh uh
uh almost no and and and and I read this
in in I I I watched this in several
documentaries but I read this in a
couple different academic papers the
idea is it's reasonable to assess that
no confederate soldier fought for the
right to own slaves as none of them did
it was only a very small portion of
wealthy Plantation and Factory owners
who did the soldiers were not mobilized
Under The View that slavery must be
defended they were mobilized Under The
View that Union soldiers were rampaging
through their state and threatening
their families if it were the issue that
the union did not invade not it is
likely that they would not have been
able to have mobilized a milit military
force to fight the union because the the
the average young man at the time was
not going to go to war to defend some
rich guys slaves well the South if the
South doesn't secede then the north
doesn't invade and we wouldn't let any
part of the country and secede right now
but so this is my point the the the
fighting of the war was over for the
north the secession of the South and
whether they had the right to do it so
fair point to those saying it was
State's rights to secede versus the
federal versus the union but that is why
the north was fighting you have no right
to seced L say Grant said you have a
right to try but if you lose we we own
you basically and um it's a brilliant
assessment of the issue pertaining to
the Revolution and how we won and the
Civil War and how they lost he basically
was was he was basically saying the
Americans the colonist at the time this
is 80 years prior so not even that long
for them it's kind of wild right he's
like they decided they shouldn't be
ruled by the crown they fought they won
congratulations the Confederates feel
like they shouldn't be a part of the
Union anymore they fought they lost we
own it that that's who you're being
ruled by now but so uh I think it's
important to break down this distinction
because when everyone says what was the
cause of the Civil War I think slavery
is an absolutely Fair assessment like
this led to the great contention in
politics why was a civil war fought is
an entirely different question the union
demanded the right to the states the
southern states said no and why uh and
and that's actually I would say why was
there why did the Civil War begin is
states rights versus uh uh uh the
federal issue and why was the war fought
and that is an invasion from the North
like plain plain and simple uh if if the
union for has decided to let the South
seced there's no war none secession is
not war so what started this what
started the war the northern Invasion
like I mean there you go they decided
like you do not have right to suceed so
Mr opman it sort of begs the question uh
did you bring this Union Jack Flag to
this former Confederate not a Union Jack
all um the Union Jack is the British
flag what it What was the just the Union
flag Yan flag Yan flag this Yankee flag
yeah did you bring this yank flag to
this former Confederate State just to
Mog on him a bit I think West Virginia
was the first state to leave the
Confederacy I could be wrong you can
look it up they were it was Tak I
believe West Virginia is
like statehood done dirty man that's
right did you also know tidbit uh West
Virginia's original proposed name was
kanwa oh that's cool sounds like am
River I believe it is just like Illinois
or um Ohio you know right uh uh yeah
yeah yes words uh I be I believe like uh
most of the Midwestern states are right
what do you mean uh Done Dirty what do
you means West Virginia was formed
through a vote should we break away from
Virginia and stay with theion
it's really easy to win a loyalist vote
when the young men are forced to go off
and fight a war for Virginia to defend
the state and once all of the men had
left to fight in the war those that
remained voted to fracture off the state
from Virginia and join the union jeez
and when the young men returned after
the war and were like this is Virginia
the Supreme Court ruled no it's not
Virginia uh it's it's actually um big
Supreme Court uh case that happened just
after the Civil War War Virginia argued
not the war is over Virginia must be
retained as whole and they said nope so
it's pretty wild the thing Virginia
would have been huge it was huge it was
massive West Virginia is huge and
Virginia huge on but oh me too I mean
it's done dirty but West Virginia is
based and Virginia Is Not So based I
love it here we need more States yeah
more the barrier it is fascinating to be
here like guys if you come out here you
will you walk 10 ft and there's like a
placard with a picture talking about the
Civil War and what happened MH we drive
up the road like 10 miles and and TM is
right here and the Cannons are are there
memorialized and there's like a bunch of
different plaques explaining what
happened man it's crazy gb's 40 minutes
away I know a local Gravedigger and he's
always just like yeah I go to church
with him and he's like I found more
Civil War bones you know he's always
finding from from the battlefield we got
a civil war bayonet oh nice and Shane
you're convinced on the ghosts on the
ghosts well I think uh Landscapes can be
haunted by Mass trauma yeah yeah they
call that Phantom DNA yeah it's in there
photons bind to DNA and then when the
DNA is removed the photons stay there
for a while I don't know about the
photons but think of all the blood spill
on this on this land I mean in all these
towns near where we're at they were all
turned into hospitals to saw limbs off
men right there's churches where they're
like yeah the wood here is still stained
from blood you know and what book can we
read about that oh that's inverted World
Volume 2 is isn't it wild that like if
they just knew to pour Whiskey on some
guys like if
take take the bullet out pour water on
it and then pour whiskey into it you
might be okay like here's some leeches
and some whiskey just but they would
drink the whiskey while getting the
amputation like bro just clean it they
didn't they didn't know it's wild wash
your hands was what like 1907 or
something people didn't wash their and
that's like I love the story of when
they were like discovering germs and the
doctor's like perhaps you should wash it
was cuz women were dying in childb birth
or whatever and he was like maybe if we
wash our hands before that's crazy what
are you talking
about and then they did and then like
women started dying less I was watching
I it might be the kings in General's
YouTube channel there's a few channels
where they do like historical battle
document nice and one of it's Civil War
I think no no it's like um uh like a map
and it'll show like the General's faces
as the troops move around on the map and
they'll tell you like from the south
Stonewall Jackson came in and split his
troops off General this guy and this guy
but Sherman or whoever and it it became
very real like things started to seem
like they were my friends and I was
picturing them outside running through
these Hills and it's like just with B
that's something I I walked away from
that inverted world book that I wrote
when I was in Georgia is like even those
battles are so contested amongst
historians I saw two men almost get into
a fist fight in a historic uh like
Museum because they were disagreeing on
whether or not uh Confederates no I'm
sorry uh loyalists this is a revolution
we on horses or not and they got so mad
and they couldn't even agree on that and
you look at all these documents they
don't even gett Gettysburg is awesome oh
I really recommend anybody ever get a
chance cuz they got awesome food they've
got chocolate shops they got souvenirs
everywhere you can buy cannonballs
there's so much like Civil War refu
still everywhere to be found it's kind
of nuts and then when we drove up there
cuz like seriously 40 minutes away
there's like just reenactors everywhere
like you every road you're driving down
there's like guys in in in like costume
that's kind of weird I don't understand
why You' want to do that but I love the
history so I I mean I grew up in West
Point I grew up around rean actors it's
just part of life we went to
um it's it's really crazy I can't
remember where we were I think were you
with us when we went to that aquarium
and we we watched the uh the the story
of the Ironclad yes that was awesome
North Carolina or something yeah yeah
and I don't I don't remember exactly
where it was but they were yeah I think
it was North Carolina the Ironclad and
its invention was like insane the
Confederates were going house to house
and and and confiscating farm tools to
make iron for ironclads because these
ironclads were like basically
indestructible steam ships that could go
up up River and down river and could
deflect cannon fire and there's a crazy
story where uh and and the people
listening might know the story better
than me um we were watching this this
video that was like you know show and
there was like sounds and you can the
lights it was like it was an aquarium
and uh they talked about it I guess it's
like an artificial Reef or something but
anyway this union guy as their their
ship is approaching the iron CL and
they're fighting it's having no effect
he just like instructs them to keep
firing and then runs up someone did do
it and then he like pulls the quarter
whatever fire the cannon and someone
yells no The Cannonball hits the
Ironclad bounces in the air lands back
on the ship blowing him up killing him
yeah dude the ironclads that was amazing
dude war is nuts dude the union was they
call him Sherman neck ties you guys know
about those they would to stop the flow
of you know food and ammo on the
railroads they would burn the the train
tracks and then wrap them off the ground
in around trees those are called Sherman
neck ties wa like they would take the
they would vend the metal after heating
them up so much so they could then move
them wow the train would just go off and
crash yeah they could they would stop
yeah dude Sherman was just like a
psychopath Sherman was our first atom
bomb we sent him to the South to blow it
up and he didn't care he didn't care he
killed freed slaves he was he was n he
was nuts he was torching Farms he was
just it was I think it was it's not the
first but for like American history it
is the Advent of scorched Earth policy
yeah and he learned it at West Point
we're all the generals in the Civil War
he was like I'm going to show you how
it's really done William T Sherman
William T shman they named the tank
after him the Sherman tank that's right
for the record that channel is called
history Marsh MC the the video I was
looking at was called Chancellor Ville
uh I don't know if you guys know
Chancellorsville I've never been there
before Robert E Le's greatest battle
Robert E Lee apparently was just a
brilliant brilliant guy fighting for his
home state of Virginia also went to West
Point he was like friends with a lot of
the other Generals in the union they
were like knew each other and stuff yeah
it's unbelievable and they fought
together in what the Mexican American
War I believe yeah yeah they're all Bo I
mean Jefferson Davis went to West Point
all of them except for Lincoln yeah
Lincoln was just some Outsider he was a
boxer in Illinois right uh boxer lawyer
yeah crazy tall lanky guy yep and then
uh he was not he was a staunch racist uh
everyone was he wanted to send all black
people back to Liberia is it was it
Liberia Liberia pretty sure that's what
they did right there many stories of of
brothers fighting against each other oh
yeah yeah so it was it was so but but
then this is the beautiful thing
I mean West Point they started the
association of grads I believe that's
what it's called after the war to be
like all right we all fought and killed
you know each other but let's get let's
be brothers again and it's it's pretty
amazing so Liberia which is in West uh
West Africa started in the 19th century
between 1822 and 1861 15,000 freed and
freeorn African-Americans along with
3,198 afoc carians relocated to Liberia
gradually developing an Americo Liberian
identity the settlers carried their
culture and tradition with them Liberia
declared independence uh July 26 1847
which the US did not recognize until
1862 but I I believe they also had like
um Americanized like Constitution and
policy and things like that I think they
had like a Southern Culture too where
they had slaves and slave owners too if
I'm not mistaken yeah they had they
adopted what the plantation system in
the South and then just projected it on
to their we like this human slavery
thing that's been going on for the since
the beginning of time
no it's it's it's really effed up
because um it was really also all they
knew it was the only economic system
they knew it was the you know they were
former they emancipated slaves and um I
don't know they they did the evil that
was done onto them onto others but uh
you you know people need to understand
too A lot of people don't realize this
the north was super racist yeah just
abject racism and you know how it's
really easy to understand segregation
continued in all of these places until
the end of the' 50s or whatever until
the Civil Rights Act even like ' 60s 60s
yeah so this idea that these
abolitionists were like we oppose racism
it's like no they were they were very
racist well I'm sure the John Brown
types were not segregationists but you
know what people also don't understand
too like people really need to read this
uh there were slaves that got paid the
one of one of the things that happens is
everybody sees these movies and these
stories where it's a plantation where a
guy's being beaten which happened is
horrifying is really bad and it was a
lot of slavery but there were also
slaves who worked in homes there were
slave slaves who worked in shops and
there were slaves who received pay and
there were slaves who bought their own
Freedom with the money that they earned
working as a slave and I think it's
important that people understand the
nuances and the context around a lot of
this because then you'll understand how
it was possible you know like I read
about Frederick Douglas and I read about
these other uh other freed slaves and
it's like they bought their slavery they
bought their freedom and I'm like wait
what and then I'm like oh interesting
the system was not the movie system
people think it was it is actually much
more complicated and nuanced albeit the
whole thing in my view completely wrong
and I think uh everyone's kind of
realized that around the world except
for maybe North Africa I mean it goes to
show how long it takes for ideology to
change I mean and it's going to take you
know another 50 hundred years for a lot
of the modern inverted racism to go away
like it's really embedded it takes
Democrats are put getting CPR to racism
as hard as they can ex maybe but uh time
is more about motion and the for
information to travel so with the
internet speeding up yeah data transfers
so quickly that metam it can metamorph
uh ideologies rapidly that's very true
for good or
evil it's a matter of making people
comfortable manipulating them casually I
think we're there are people who
experien segregation still alive today I
don't know that's that's wild it's
called vaccine passports but there uh I
I black and white segregation vaccine
passport stuff was wrong but black and
white I know but I do think we may
actually I'll say this I I don't know if
we're tending towards an end of gender
segregation that's what the the gender
ideologues have pushed for using the
same argument for uh uh that that was
used against racial segregation
considering uh you know Shane Gillis
hosting SNL this weekend certainly think
the woke are losing so I'm not so sure
that will happen but uh a bunch of the
left have made the argument that gender
segregation is no different than racial
segregation and there's no argument for
it especially when the 1964 Civil Rights
Act forbids discrimination the basis of
sex so was a case in California where uh
some guy sued the like women in
Computing Club he's like a university
had a club for women in Computing it's
not fair I should be allowed to join
you're discriminating against me and the
courts ruled there's a club that men can
join so it's not discriminatory if
there's a club you can join they're not
they're not saying you can't be in a
club this one's just for women that
one's for men by the way while that's an
interesting real quick that that that
argument uh lends itself
to segregation if there's two bathrooms
and one for white people wants for black
people then you're not being
discriminated against but we've already
said no to that so this case in
California seems question uh
questionable which resulted in leftists
now arguing you cannot create two
bathrooms for two protected categories
that is discrimination under the law
period and so now we're at the point
where legally they're correct absolutely
if the 6 1964 Civil Rights Act says you
cannot discriminate on the base of sex
or race and we've determined that
bathrooms based on race are
discrimination then it follows that sex
bathrooms also are but we also have a
common sense and moral line where we're
like men and women are different males
and females are different that's why we
do this to which the left has now
countered the argument saying that used
to be the position of the
segregationists that black and white
people were different and so it was for
safety reasons they had different spaces
they're trying to use the exact same
same arguments many conservatives and
Libertarians have pointed out the 1964
Civil Rights Act has created the path to
wokeness to create things where like
dudes are going in girls bathrooms do
you buy that it's on the same level um I
do think men and women's bathroom is
equal to segregation but I support that
type of segregation I like yeah we are
segregating people by gender right gend
but like with you know say say it was
only a a black area at a college I don't
think we should have that um I think
it's okay to segregate by genders I
don't think we should do you think do
you think that that new modern race
segregation at schools is on the same
level as historic yes uh wait wa ask
that one more time yeah wait what I'm
saying you know if there was like what
Brett Weinstein you're saying like when
they do these POC only rooms it's the
same segregation I'm saying do you I'm
asking if you think it's the same level
of segregation as it was traditionally
oh no way no I think
this and it was when it was
institutionalized in every facet where
like you couldn't go into a certain
store or whatever that's a higher degree
of segregation
so you think that it's lesser it's not
it's a fact you're asking a fact based
question if if if there's 10 if there if
there's a 100 universities that have
within their University system one
instance where they've created a black
only space that is factually less sure
than the entirety of the country having
segregation as a standard standardized
policy I'm with you El lot I think that
segregating based on G sex is very
different than racial segregation we've
made it a dirty word but uh I think what
we're actually when we're actually
talking about isn't a bad thing um go on
uh what can you determine about someone
based on the color of their skin like
nothing almost nothing almost some
genetic ancestry the re let's let's
expand this though because a lot of
people are like oh come on no no no like
seriously like a dude from Somalia and a
dude from Haiti are different people
they have a dark skin tone but they're
going to be very different that smes are
shorter than Haitians who are taller so
what's your determination skin color is
not a good metric for for any kind of
segregation you can't you can't even
really determine someone 's ethnic
background or what part of the world
they come from based on the color of
their skin they like I went to Egypt I
thought I was Egyptian yep and I'm I'm
not I go to Spain they thought they
thought I was Hispanic I go to Mexico
they think I'm Mexican they they can't
tell so how someone looks isn't a good
determining Factor however males and
females globally everywhere period are
different and so that I get yep it's
that lady from The View recently found
out she's not as Puerto Rican oh man
that was so funny look look look let's
do this sunny uh Sunny htin shocked to
find she's descended from Spanish slave
holders wait is this one of those weird
one like people can also be descendants
of slaves if their ancestors were raped
by their slave owners and like well of I
just want to make but see your reaction
wow I'm I'm I'm a little bit in shock I
I just always thought of myself as
Puerto Rican you know half Puerto Rican
I didn't think I was uh my family was
originally from Spain Fain and
slaveholders yeah so how are you feeling
my friend um I just um I think it's
actually pretty interesting that um my
husband and I have shared Roots yeah so
I I do appreciate that um she married
it's great for our children descendant
to know this information who was it
there was a big story where it was like
another view person they found out they
were descendant a descendant of slave
owners and all the people lot people on
the right were like hahaa and I'm like
oh bro means like the slave owner raped
their slave come on yeah that's probably
what it means so uh we were I was we
were hanging out with uh some dude some
guy today uh we're hanging out with um
Matt from bass records good dude and uh
I I don't know if he wanted me to tell
the story or not but I'll say his name
because he made he made the point but um
I've made this this statement to a lot
of people before when you know it comes
up to my ethnic background and being
part Korean I'm like well well I'm uh uh
you know I'm part Korean but a little
bit Japanese like you know my mom's 40%
Korean 10% Japanese everyone goes oo cuz
you know what that means yeah that does
that that's it's not a Romeo and Juliet
Japanese guy being like I don't care
what my family thinks I love you I love
you too H it's more like burn the house
down and take the women kind of thing
you know what I mean that still causes
tensions in South Korea and Japan to the
St dude they're both the South Koreans
are are totally ethnos supremacists yeah
well many many people in those those
countries but I mean like South Koreans
the younger generation is is moving away
from it but they are very ethnos
supremacist there's a famous clip now of
uh from what's it I think it's called
bad friends with Andrew Santino and
Bobby whatever Bobby Lee right and then
he's uh he's like saying oh Koreans
never did slavery whatever and they fact
check him and it turns out Koreans had
slavery for like over a thousand years
Bren slavery Bobby Lee constantly talks
about how racist they are I know yeah of
course of course but just pointing out
the fact that like that's that's a
that's the reality is that racism has
been around way longer and slavery has
been around Way Long longer than just
suddenly in the 1800s in the US and
everyone always get they're also a very
patriarchal society exem exem very very
patriarchal Koreans Koreans yeah yeah
they they they're mostly Korean
supremacists yeah they believe that they
are the best Superior race on the planet
and they have no problem telling you
that and they're like of course they
call it the Korean noi system which is
commonly associated with slavery and
social hierarchy in premodern Korea and
for people uh the Japanese and Koreans
who should be allies geop geopolitically
right now especially considering what's
going on with China still beef with one
another over um the conf the of the
Imperial Army soal who they still
rever over in Japan but we don't need a
on our allies now when I went to
South Korea I went to this Museum where
I learned about a great General a naval
General and it was really hilarious
because uh it each like room you walk
through depicted a great Victory but the
funny thing I noticed was every great
Victory the size of the Navy was getting
smaller and so it's like in the first
one there's this big Fleet and it's like
the great General routed the Japanese
and forced their ships off and I was
like wow I walk in the next room and
then it's like facing insurable odds he
was able to drive back to Japanese
forces with a small force and I was like
interesting and then finally in the end
it's like him and like a small handful
of guys and I was like you mean to tell
me like he was losing the whole time
right it's a nice way of putting it
right yeah but they like highlight the
great stories of his successes like fair
point but it was an attrition so yeah
sometimes a retreat can be what you call
successful if the enemy loses more than
you lose in the retreat that's a
successful Retreat dude we have um where
was this in uh in New Jersey I think
there's the um I forgot what the name of
the park is but they got the story of I
think it's Mercer I can't remember the
guy's name this dude who was like
surrounded by the British and then he
just like told him this kill him he
would never like betray the country
there's cannons everywhere and it's like
where Washington cross the Delaware or
something it's fun to go to these places
growing up in Chicago we didn't have any
of this right it doesn't exist it's like
you just live in Chicago but then you
move out to the East Coast and it's just
like these plaques everywhere talking
about the war out here it's really crazy
cuz we're like 5 minutes from John Brown
raid HQ where John Brown organized the
Harper's fairy Ray like Harper Fair's
literally here down the street and uh
what what is it what's going on no it's
the his house is the only house I ever
thought should have a black lives matter
sign outside of it like that one
actually makes sense but he he tried to
trigger a slave revolt and they wouldn't
do it yeah yeah they were like nah get
out of here first man hung by the state
for treason treason was he first I feel
like he was first they ban him from the
ballot what's funny is the local casino
this is kind of wild the local casino
has uh their $25 chips at Charlestown
has John Brown some of them have John
Brown on it and I'm like it's kind of
wild because like depending on who wins
the war the most vile and Despicable
people will be heralded as Heroes
Sherman Sherman Sherman's just another
version of brown but on a larger scale
uh well no brown brown was definitely a
terrorist Al he might been fighting for
things that were morally right and I
think is a dangerous person to idolize
because I mean there are a lot of people
who believe passionately some political
things right now and shouldn't justify
violence to try to achieve those ends
but that's what John Brown did and I
think some leftists especially IDE um
idolize him but leading way very
dangerous but they would see him as far
right today CU he's a Christian super
Christian that's why he was against
slavery you know like but they wouldn't
care like they wouldn't agree with Putin
Den not you think John Brown would
support gay marriage no no absolutely
not he do a lot of bad things about all
these things y Sherman though that guy
was just like want and disregard for
human life I think you could argue that
Sherman was trying to end the conflict
quicker via his brutal means to save
more American lives I think he want an
excuse to murder and Destroy um I think
you're at war with somebody and I mean
you're trying to end the war within your
own country I think there's that's war
crimes when you're you're you're in
charge of killing all these people he
killed innocent people freed slaves he
killed people on the sidelines in the
periphery of the war it wasn't just he
was going after the Confederates they
just burned everything we could go
through individual instances but like I
think war is terrible and war is
terrible like he was trying to end the
war but we should avoid war crimes like
do you think we should have dropped adom
bomb uh yeah I definitely think I I
don't know if I agree with that either
and I see the two as the same thing as
desperate reasons to end a war no I
think Imperial Japan kind of gets a like
looking back they get a good rep they
were literally the Nazis of the Pacific
yeah they were in so um this at a point
where we we were in Total War uh with
over with Japan um it's over until it's
not how many hundreds of thousands of
American troops lives are worth trying
to invade the Homeland where the
Japanese were trying to say they're
going to fight until every last life I
also think it's really easy for us
looking back to go oh well maybe you
know maybe you actually should have just
invaded would have been the large
largest amphibious assault on the
mainland ever how you know that I agree
with looking back with 2020 Vision or
you have you know have 2020 Vision but I
Al I also the war crimes and the the
definition was different
is there any War where there aren't any
war crimes though I feel like we can say
that every time for every side I'm sure
the uh Confederates committed war crimes
uh I don't I'm too Wy to look into them
was what were considered war crimes back
well you could look at the was it were
the Geneva conventions yeah did they
have Geneva there were no war crimes
back I mean there's still ethically and
morally war crimes I'm spacing right now
who had Anderson prison was that the the
South Andersonville was that the north
of the South that movie is so good South
was South that's my favorite Civil War
movie prob that was insane I saw the
movie but it was kind of like a Unit 731
in Japan without all the modern
technology for like the human VI section
and like experimentation right there was
no they weren't dry freezing hands and
shattering them but it was so horrific
also they had literal slaves in the
South um yeah right right I I still
don't agree with everything Sherman did
and I don't agree dropping the B you
know and every I mean not the totally
for the second part you don't have to
agree with every I don't find know
anybody who I could agree with
everything they did they did but um I
think you could say Sherman helped end
the war sooner than it would have
otherwise I feel like it's the same
argument I'm using for Japan actually
you know what on the same I don't I
don't think I think if the context of
the Civil War happened today I I'm not
so convinced the north would be able to
win I think the South would be crazy I
think the issue is the the speed of
communications I think that if videoos
started emerging like the psychological
effect of uh uh of these of video and
information would have such a dramatic
change I mean
the uh the march to the sea I don't know
could happen in an urban environment
today because the moment the intern like
the uh the North and South were
competing for international supplies
they needed trade the South I think they
were trading cotton with with the UK
that's where that that flag came from
British boat a British boat yeah They
seized it so uh uh the north blockaded
the South trying and cut their supplies
what would happen internationally if
videos emerged of let's just say in the
in like literally 1861 but with with
internet video videos emerge of
civilians being shot in Cold Blood by
Union Soldiers
International like relations for the for
the north would shatter and they'd say
no no no no we we did not supply and we
don't condone that because they would
face revolts in their own countries over
the supplying of War over the
facilitating of war crimes it would
cause them a lot of problems is that new
a24 movie out yet no no Tim I think
because I think there would be people
there could be clear video of war crimes
happening of whatever Civil War would
happen there would still be people
denying it there would people be blaming
the other side oh they killed their own
people I'm just think about the October
7th attack and the amount of gaslighting
that will exist even if there was
footage of people being slaughtered and
killed obviously people who were
civilians people don't care and we
disgusting I you're you're right to a
certain degree but the October 7th
attack has resulted in the left
shattering and the the you you've got
Michael apore this was his turn he hates
Trump all of a sudden he's wearing a
star of David and he says what the is
wrong with these people that's opened a
door for him to start exploring more
about what they're doing and now he's
like cops are being beaten when people
when people realize black lives matter
was celebrating these paragliders I mean
look I got no beef with someone
criticizing Israel's mil military
actions it's a war okay by all means
please criticize people's military
actions it should be done and there
there is a a risk to Israel
in that a lot of this propaganda for is
is being supported by the left but man
what Hamas did really really messed them
messed up uh the progressive left in
this country Sherman's March to the Sea
was absolutely brutal I mean it is
historically Cannon he was destroying
civilian targets and killing civilians
did not care it was scorched Earth
everything must
burn what I on that scale you know uh
the problem with the Confederates one of
the reasons they lost they thought all
they had to do was prove they had the
military might and the fighting would
stop they did not realize the union was
going to burn their children and burn
homes to the ground to win this and not
that I'm a fan of you know the what what
the Confederacy would have implemented
it's a good thing they lost but holy
crap I'm not a fan of dropping nuclear
bombs on Japan but at the First Battle
of Bull Run they repel the the union and
they're like that's it the war is over
there's not going to be a war we just
proved that they can't come in here and
then they came in and started just
brutalizing the South this mobilized the
South feeling feeling that they were
being invaded and then eventually a turn
happened where um I forget which general
might have been I don't know Jackson
they felt that uh the only way to
actually win this was to invade the
North and put pressure on the North to
stop supporting this war civilians in
the north need to understand what the
war was and it was an opportunity
opportunity for them to seize resources
Unfortunately they moved into Gettysburg
didn't go too well for the Confederates
but I imagine what would happen if the
International Community was watching
something akin to the march to the sea
it is hard enough for US troops dealing
with IEDs and strapping like they they
strap bombs to kids and then you end up
with American soldiers being uh being
placed into a Military Tribunal or
whatever or court marshalled because of
the perception of what they did not what
they had to do to defend themselves
there's no way I could see Union
soldiers in many of these circumstances
being able to defend the actions if they
were blasted out on the internet around
the world and that would cause problems
for the Union's ability to supply itself
that being said they had a lot of
resources in and of themselves I don't
know that you know what would have
happened if they didn't have
international support but I'm sure no
anyway we should go to super chats
because we went a little we went a
little over here so we'll go to super
chats Civil War chat inspired by fun
yeah smash that like button subscribe to
the channel share the show with your
friends head over to
timcast.net nipple says PE PE poo poo
yeah I will read your Super Chat thank
you agreed token black ey says Tim poool
you have been called you are the Mayor
West Virginia needs time to take the
mantle the mayor of where Charlestown I
don't want to be a
mayor not interested I think it was
because I was saying like if I was ever
like if I got elected president or
Governor Trump you ain't seen nothing
with Trump like VI no way dude I would I
would I would not just go to My AG and
be like can we get criminal charges I
would go on television I would do a live
stream and issue a statement about the
the requirement for this nation and the
reasons why certain individuals must be
criminally charged must face an
investigation and a trial by a jury of
their peers and I would formally declare
like it must be done now I give it to
those in the executive branch with the
authority to make those positions happen
but Mark you know let my intentions be
clear to the American people certain
people in this country must be
criminally charged they're like like Joe
Biden the barisma stuff mhm it is it is
absurd and they use this documents case
as the shield he's not going to be
criminally charged because he's a
daughtering old fool and you know
they're really saying he'll never face
charges over brisma Nah if if I was I I
was saying like if I was the governor of
West Virginia I would make do a public
assessment or a public statement where
I'd say law enforcement of the state of
West Virginia must immediately begin the
process of an of a raid on CBP
facilities in in in the Eastern
Panhandle and I have already called on
on to the extent that I can the attorney
general and our prosecutors to seek out
H uh warrants from judges allowing State
forces to raid that facility for
evidence of human trafficking and
smuggling operations they have engaged
in let them panic and people might say
but then you're informing them you're
doing it oh yes that's the point and
then if they don't do it I'll say hey I
made my declaration I did what I could
do I don't expect it to be dictatorial
that everyone just does when I bang a
gavl I expect them to go through the
legal process and go to a judge and make
the argument but I want to make sure
everybody knows you got this big CBP
facility you got CBP agents out here
they know the show and I'm like there's
videos of them working with cartels it's
it's it's it's mindblowing to see like
the cartels bring these people up and
they're armed CBP is like howdy and they
open the gate and bring them in I'm
disgusted by that anyway raid uh Area 51
and R Patterson while you're at it
please I mean I feel like depending on
on the public and apparent crimes that
need to be you know held to account I
don't know that A51 has those and I
respect the right of the US military to
have secrets depending on those secrets
we can't just like announce to the world
our military capabilities our security
be compromised but you know let's read
more Jennifer linto says I want to shout
out my husband Shawn who has largely
been an influence in my recovery from
leftist ideology he loves this show and
so do I this is the way shout out
that's that's the way you know husbands
life s an or s h a w n s a an nice dude
it's a healthy marriage that's right Ian
Kenny says it blows my mind that I live
in Wisconsin and never heard about the
chipa wa Falls school until last night
chipa falls is on the other side of the
state from me closer to the Minnesota
border that's where that shooting almost
took place
yeah Raymond g Stanley Jr says oh no
guys I watched the Tucker V Putin
interview MSM was right I'm now a Putin
puppet and I want to work with Russia to
undermine our democracy oh no oh jeez
watch out don't do those memes you might
get in trouble for something yeah stinky
man says would you buy Bud Light if
during the Super Bowl Dylan came out and
said
365 of drinking Bud Light I've grown a
beard and workout daily I built a deck
without permits I have
chickens I heard they're doing a Super
Bowl ad and it's the stupidest thing
I've ever seen oh it's already out yeah
they I mean it's it's it's stupid they
release Super Bowl ads po the Super Bowl
now they do that is Yo the commercial M
like you can watch and you're going to
be like what yeah it's just nothing it's
the
weirdest it's not even it's not even
funny like I talk about the Quizno Subs
where those stupid rat things are like
we love sandwiches or whatever and like
that's everyone remembers it this one is
not memorable at all it's just
like the stupidest random commercial I
can't believe they tried doing this
during the Super Bowl we broke the
company guys we we they're they're
broke F says elad you're a mad lad mad
take my money dad really love your
reporting style followed you all through
the summer of love I appreciate you dude
thanks for the Super Chat guys uh follow
us at timcast news on Twitter we do a
lot of great Fields reporting and other
journalists here doing a great job also
the scnr YouTube channel has all your
videos up on it so if you go to uh scnr
on YouTube subscribe you can watch
elad's reporting one of my favorites is
you running after the person in the golf
cart was that like Russell fry while he
was running yeah North Carolina great
video yeah thank you so much oh man
you're the best third I says yo Tim
please read I haven't laughed so hard in
a long time the Babylon be just dropped
the funniest article I've ever read
Biden calls for the president to step
down very
nice knowing their track record that
could become
true Venom symbient says did anyone else
see the horrible Tucker Carlson deep
fake Bitcoin ad it popped up for me
during the show sketchy whoa that means
YouTube's running it I've seeing Mr
Beast deep AI ads on like Instagram and
they they did it with Joe Rogan a while
ago yep M there was a fake ad yeah what
was that like weird supplement it was
like a testosterone thing to make your
dick bigger right and it was an AI of
Joe Rogan it sounded really weird he was
like well the thing is about this it
makes you big and then the guy was like
that's right and I'm like yo this is the
most classic scam make it bigger come on
guys hey man people spend money on
anything you know what I mean let's go
what do we got here Jason Hutchinson
says if he's too old to be held to
account he's too old to be president
this is very dumb what are we doing
that's right what should the age limit
be I don't know about age limit or yeah
just aptitude I you know maybe there
should be yeah maybe it should be 35 to
60 targu to the other side of it it's
anti-democratic you get you get left
with what you pick we we're picking
these older people the Democrats pick
Joe Biden then why have a lower Limit Oh
no we shouldn't have a lower limit
either and Democratic 5-year-old I mean
they wouldn't have a good caucus nobody
would want to vote for them but yeah
5-year-old I I actually fear fake
presidents that we're going to come to
the point where everyone's going to be
watching the news and there's going to
be a guy who makes arguments and says
all these things and he's going to be AI
generated and not real but no one knows
because everyone just sees him in these
videos just like all the boyfriends and
girlfriends right now I'm going to take
bucko downstairs so I wanted to say
hello and goodbye for everyone that
hasn't seen them yet you guys match a
littleit in Cas yeah you match yeah they
do match goas I'll be back Mr bcus
seeing his way out he came up here
before the show and he jumped on on the
table and just laid in front of me with
his like just flat and not a good sign
so you know we let him stick around but
uh it's just impossible to know what to
do because uh he's on all these drugs
and the drugs do cause problems but they
allev alleviate some problems as well we
got him stem cells and so I'm like what
if we got him stem cells and they're
working but the drugs he's on is
actually inhibiting his potential
recovery what do we do and so it's just
like stay the court course I guess but
he got real sick the other day collapsed
pissed himself didn't couldn't move so
I've been giving him raw beef which I
don't know is the right thing to do but
I have two thoughts on it one is you
know if he's about to die and he was
supposed to die a year ago little man
gets to have his last meal it's going to
be what he wants he want enjo that the
most he he goes nuts for it there it is
so I give him a little bit but I'm also
hoping that I've read a bunch of studies
about raw raw meat diets for Animals I'm
hoping that it is beneficial to him in
some way as a very low phosphorous meat
maybe this actually can get him what he
needs and I doubt it but I'm also kind
of like dude is on his last days Quality
quality of life it matters I don't know
D you said that a year ago and he's
still going I didn't want to bring that
up every time I come here it's always
the last day yeah but he weighs nothing
now like last la like last year he was
sick and they said he was going to live
for a week we got him a bunch of drugs
we got him hydration therapy we got him
on stem cells and he's stabilized but he
is slowly withering away so so when we
see him collapse piss himself and then
struggle to move we're like he might
have died right there on the spot so
it's kind of like that's the worst we've
seen it and then when he came up here
and jumped on the table and the way he
laid down it looked like he was
struggling to move like he was just
burned out he's losing weight can't and
we're like we got to figure out how to
put weight on him but if he can't
because his kidneys are busted what can
you do you know every day is a blessing
it's brutal cuz every time everyone
comes here they're like oh is he old and
I'm like no he's five he just has a
heart problem a heart defect genetic
heart defect and underdeveloped kidneys
there's nothing we could do we were
going to get him a kidney transplant but
because of his heart we can't they do
this thing where you adopt a a cat
that's to be put down and they share the
kidneys and you have you have to adopt
both cats so you save both their lives
wow and so we were like can we do this
and they said Mr Bogus will die if you
give him a kidney transplant because of
his heart he can't take it we're like
damn yeah we did the right thing he's
eating heavily right now he went right
for the food nice that's good he
hungered that's good all right thinker
for Life says did we forget Obama poked
the bear during Sochi
Olympics the uh let's see what is it LG
gays didn't like the Russian law that
forbids gay influence of children so
Obama sent our top Advocate Billy Jean
King
really yeah Sochi is wild the Olympics
are wild because like the reports are
that they all just bang each other
non-stop have you guys read that in the
Villages yeah and then they make the
Olympic babies because they're
supposedly be genetic studs so the
Olympics are like athletic eugenist well
I went to school University of Utah when
you put that word on it that'll make
anything sound but I went to school
University of Utah and that's like where
they had like the the O2 Salt Lake City
games like the whole the whole uh
athlete Village or whatever is basically
where like the dorms are and that yeah
I've heard a lot of stories about that
from the the old staff over there so
tazwell says why does Ian look like a
character from balers Gate 3 tonight cuz
Richie Jackson gave me this clothed me
well I clothed myself but uh Richie
Jackson gave me the outfit and he is is
a Bard or I guess he would be is Richie
a Bard is Richie more of a rogue than a
Bard he's kind of like a no he's not a
he carry a Rapier around if he was in
balder's Gate UNG guard I think Bard
Richie yeah he's an athlete he's not
really he looks like a Bard have school
of Swords or College of Swords or
whatever it's called like a non a non-m
musical Bard no he's a musical guy he's
super musical he loves music he can tell
you everything about rock and roll he
knows all of it only Richie only Richie
will tell you can ask him the most
obscure Rock question he'll have the
answer for you definitely
a let's go OMG puppy says releasing a
spy wouldn't get Putin anything Western
press wouldn't reward him it wouldn't
phase the neocons or lessen their
obsession with destroying Russia no but
it could press public support in
negative position and that's what
they're desperately trying to avoid
that's what they're scared of that being
said I think the evidence here is this
dude Evans got information that Putin's
scared of what I don't understand about
that though is why they don't trade him
and then Putin just scoop up another
American journalist or another American
in Russia so big fat Irving says Russia
has Evan gershkovich Ukraine has Gonzalo
Lera why is one reporter more important
than the other uh Gonzalo may be dead I
believe it was his father who said that
he was uh he had died so right it is
funny that in the in the United States
they don't care at all about Gonzalo l
so yeah sorry Evan your machine the
machine here hates you for what you are
Frontline Texans says to him I'm curious
what makes you believe the media would
report if Tucker succeeded in bringing
him back and if they did it's not likely
that they would spin it as Tucker is a
Russian puppet and it was staged they
could I'm saying it would amplify the
Tucker story no matter what good or bad
it would make it the biggest thing in
the in the
country the rescuing of of of an
American journalist Tucker already has
the eyeballs on him now you add in the
rescuing of a journalist good on Tucker
for asking not that it didn't you know
didn't work but good
luck all right Steven SC scay says Ian
cron started working out Found Jesus and
then realized that America actually
should impose righteous lawful and
proper rule upon the world this happened
tonight Jesus is pretty cool I worked
out earlier today and yes American
constitutionalism is legitimate Ian's
been calling for uh uh you know neocon
policy now for a long time I just think
we need to inspire people to do it for
themselves I don't think walking around
being like do my thing is not that has
not worked and I don't imagine would but
when people have had enough and they're
like what they have is better I want
what they have and they're looking at me
and our country then we'll see them have
their own decentralized
Revolution Eric Elman says for
preserving the flag yes and uh Devon
Porter said Tim I'm a mil milw work
drafter I work for a company that builds
casew work I can draw a case for that
flag so like a case with like a glass
front so it's on display because if
that's the case what's the best way to
get in touch uh should is he able to
like DM you or something or message you
on Twitter yeah this a guy yeah hit me
up on Twitter send me a DM admin
scanner.com yeah you'll get it so Deon
Porter if you heard that admin at scnr
scr right sr.com or hit up Ian on
Twitter and we'll get to work on that uh
that display case yeah you probably
better going with Bill since you know we
should all I will also get one if you
can uh we have a Civil War Union muskets
never been fired not even dry fired and
uh I would love to get a case for that
and put it like on display too it's
right over there it's just been sitting
against the wall
yeah actual Union uh there's like 10,000
of them they made them had them sitting
around never used them wow yep super
cool heavy crazy rifled musket crazy
stuff it was cool we go antiquing yo if
you're in West Virginia antiquing dude
there's an antique shop full of Nazi
paraphernalia it's crazy Michael mice
would love that so uh where is it at
it's um it's in the it's in the Eastern
Panhandle there's just so many antique
shops but there's this one that is where
is it it's close to Martinsburg south of
Martinsburg I don't know exactly which
one it is but there's like it's they
malls basically so people will set up a
portion and they pay rent to have their
space but one guy's got a whole bunch of
World War II stuff so it's not just Nazi
but there's like a there's like a German
captured uh pistol and with like the the
the Like official thing explaining what
it is who captured it the rank of the
guy crazy stuff helmets insignias you
know I worked at auction gallery for for
about 10 years and we had uh
periodically these World War II auctions
and my boss got so mad because a
reporter came and the picture they used
of him was him with the giant swasa
behind him so in the local paper it's
just like my crazy boss and the giant
swasa ah it's amazing the the crazy
thing is uh we went to an antique shop
in Austin and they were selling a bunch
of swastikas and it seemed like the guy
who worked there actually got offended
at the idea that it was offensive I
asked I was like don't people like freak
out and he was like no he was like this
was a commonplace symbol across the
United States pre World War II and it is
on tons of advertisements buildings but
now they're all trying to erase it and
cover it up it's true south of Chicago
there's a big house that has a swasa
built into the top and they nailed
wooden blocks to to make it into a
square W but in the same orientation as
the swastika exact same they're they're
not angled they're not angled right so
it's just like and and it went the other
direction I think and then Hitler
inverted it and then tilted it
but so on the building it's just the
straight up symbol and then they put the
wood blocks to fill the Gap so it's just
a square with lines through it but you
can see it cuz you you can see the
blocks crazy man on YouTube there'll be
if you ever watch Hitler's speeches on
YouTube Forever you could just watch the
video and you'd watch it but now any
video a lot of videos made in the last
year they're like they had a little
disclaimer before you start watching and
saying we do not condone Nazism just so
you know it's like dude you don't have
to say that it's just a speech but yep
what let's grab some more Super chats
Triton 54 says Union Jack is the blue
section of the US flag flown from the
Ford end of US Navy ships is that is
that is that
right I believe Union Jack is a
reference to the UK flag I'm pretty sure
it is I don't I don't know maybe maybe
the Union Jack is on those but I don't I
don't know that never heard that before
yep Union Jack Flag British flag yeah we
uh yeah
because yeah Union Flag Union Jacks
British
well there you
go let's grab a couple more Super chats
maybe we'll just grab two Winston
Alexander says I'm half Korean white xus
Army stationed in Korean the90s was told
not to talk about being Korean since the
locals would assume my mom was a
hooker wow Jee not so much that way
today um now uh I think what I was told
was that it's more of a novelty and
there's this attitude of deep
curiosity so uh a journalist told me
that if I went to North Korea they would
be like super excited that I was there
and try and ask me everything about my
family and try and learn as much as
possible still holding like a disdainful
view of like but how did it happen you
know so there you go good fun maybe one
day Donald Trump will get reelected and
he will help being pre uh he will he
will help bring peace to the Korean
Peninsula and then I can actually go
visit go visit the uh town for which my
uh my I believe my great grand my great
great-grandfather
or is it
great-grandfather great great I think
yeah great
great-grandfather actually may be great
grandfather I don't know your mom's
grandpa or something or her
great-grandfather great my mom's great
grandfather I think yeah I think it's
great-grandfather I don't know it's hard
it's hard to track these things I to ask
my mom but uh it's funny because like
the white side of my family's easy I go
to Europe and I'm like oh so this is
Ireland ah so this is London ah so this
is Germany I go to Korea and it's like I
can't cross that line yeah so uh one
side of of my mom side of the family is
was from the south one side's from the
north but there was no North or South
back then they was just Farm Workers all
right if you haven't already smash that
like button would you kindly share the
show with your friends head over to
timcast.net you can Now launch your own
social network and app based on the Mind
software so if you go to minds.com
about networks you can launch your own
app that is connected to the
decentralized Social Web that's what
we've done with scanner on
scr.cr social world and you can get all
the scanner articles on there and apps
are coming soon for scanner on both both
stores so keep an eye out an eye out for
those and then mindfest we got coming up
April 27th at the Vulcan in Austin it's
going to be awesome um and Sean is
telling me that we need to challenge uh
Elon and Mark Cuban to come debate Dei I
I wanted to say we could bill it as uh
the white supremacist versus the
African-American yeah so thanks for
having me man what's the website you
mentioned minds.com
n
workset with an ass yeah with an ass
yeah uh my name's alad yahu I'm a
journalist here at timcast news follow
us on Twitter and Instagram and all that
good stuff uh it's been awesome thanks
for tuning in guys this is a really fun
one you can find me at Shane Cashman
online and uh tomorrow at 3 o'clock I'll
be on pop culture crisis with Brett Mary
I'm looking forward to it oh awesome
this was a good one and shout out to
Richie Jackson for giving me this
awesome shirt Bill thanks for bringing
the flag Tim good show good to see you
guys good to see you lot you too Shane I
like how you can like blend into almost
any conversation it's nice I'm a ghost
yes you are a chameleon of the Mind
Serge DPR hey uh that was a good one I
agree good show good to have you here
elad uh likewise bill as well Shane
thanks for doing the show of course uh
yeah let's uh let's hit this after show
Tim all right we will see you all over
at timcast.net thanks for hanging
out